hey
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos guys
while you're at it i have a couple
announcements we have a new clips
channel i think we just hit 13k on the
clips channel you guys did that in what
two
11 days 15 13k on the clips channel so
let's get to 15k that is our goal by the
end of the week on top of that we have a
new membership tier if you guys want to
have a one-on-one call with me once a
month sign up for our fourth membership
tier on top of that guys the second half
of the show is gonna be members only the
first half is going to be subscribers
only tonight
like the video on your way in a like is
free i'm really tired of you ninja
watchers okay i'm very very tired of
this you guys all watch you don't even
subscribe i see the analytics it's not
cool so like the video while you're at
it um our member of the week is sentient
it's everyone cloud
sentience was a big supporter of the
show early on so um thank you sentience
for supporting from the beginning
because it really helped to keep us
going and anybody that wants to come on
the show dm eddie that is our recruiter
i'm only if you are in london or willing
to fly into london dm eddie if you want
to come on the show
so today
we have a lovely panel so why don't we
go around everyone say your name your
age
your relationship status and a fun fact
starting with you
alright so i'm phil
age 27
married
and the fun fact is
i make films
oh you're married you like barely get
married people on the show
go ahead
hey everyone my name is jennifer cynthia
i am 34 years old i'm in a relationship
and a fun fact about me is i was born on
the 29th of february which is a leap
year wow
hi my name is ems i'm 28. single fun
fact
i play the drums
oh sorry i play the drums
hey my name's adom i'm 21
i am single fun fact about me
[Music]
i'm born on the 6th of march which is
ghana's independence day and i'm gone in
hi guys my name is davonte uh 24 single
and fun fact about me i've got my own
podcast as well so yeah
oh that's where i've seen you before
yeah
yeah i was like you looked familiar but
i couldn't put it okay yeah go ahead hi
guys my name is sehaila i'm 29 i'm
single
and fun fact about me are like ceramics
and pottery
okay guys also i see you guys in the
chat um yes my tick tock did get banned
today
sad um we're trying to appeal it though
so maybe we could get back on the end of
the week we'll see but if you guys want
follow my backup account which is pearly
reactions on tick tock
okay but today
we have a question and this question was
asked by kevin samuels rest in peace
so the topic today is what do you have
to offer a man that you haven't given
any other
man so um
i'm gonna start with um why don't you
start i knew you was gonna say yeah yeah
see they're they're new you're a
seasoned vet
i don't i don't know the answer to that
question honestly
um
[Music]
i guess
in this stage of my life i can offer
more maturity
in my relationship
would you so you haven't offered that
before
i have but i think
with age and time and experience i've
got more mature and
i have a better understanding in
relationships okay
honestly i don't know but um
was having this conversation earlier
since every man is different i feel like
with
a different man i bring something
different to them
so i think it depends on the man
okay
um
i think like she said i just think every
man's different all relationships are
compromised getting to know each other
building together understanding each
other so i think at this stage probably
i understand myself better my
non-negotiables my negotiables so i
think
like there's more clarity now i think on
my part as to what i would require or
what
so were you offers you know what you
want
i know what i want uh-huh and i know
what i would like to gain at the same
time okay go ahead
um
i feel like there's nothing i can offer
a man
that he
can't already get
okay i mean i've
i've had a child so okay i mean yeah
okay so um question for the man what
would you guys like a girl to offer you
that you haven't gotten that she hasn't
given to another guy
peace
peace peace of mind i'm telling you
i think after a long day of just working
going to the gym just want to come home
to peace
i don't know if it's possible or if it
actually exists but yeah
and how how would a girl offer that to
you
and did anyone
and did any of the answers that they
gave sound like something you would want
of that that was a value to you
yeah um
both were their answers okay tell me why
in terms of like
maturing in a relationship i guess if
it's your first relationship
you're gonna make mistakes
and it's your first time you're not
really gonna you've never experienced it
before and you're gonna learn from your
experiences and be a better person so
it's good to like for someone to
actually be able to realize right in my
first experience i weren't really doing
what i was meant to or i didn't
understand certain things but now i'm
willing to so okay and what about you
same questions well i'm i'm married so
sorry i should say what did you get what
did i get yes uh
can at least be i mean
jenna you really don't know are you
married virgin yeah oh that's great yeah
that was that's pretty much it but i'd
say something similar like peace
okay
um do you wanna
okay okay i didn't you seem like okay
um
who okay who is the prize men or women
um for me
men and women are the prize to each
other
okay
okay you know actually no i don't accept
that answer pick one yeah pick one men
or women someone has to reach someone
someone's a prize
[Music]
in the pursuit
for happiness i think women are the
prize okay um
but as you you kind of cut off my answer
so i can't give you the answer i wanted
to give but in that yeah women are the
prize four men okay what do you guys
think i feel like women are the prize i
feel like from a young age i've always
seen the woman just sits there and the
man is always chasing after the woman so
it just looks like
the woman is the prize
okay
um
i think
it depends on what stage of life you're
at for me personally i think if we're
gonna go like just
we're just looking right now i would say
women are the prizes as in she's the
trophy on your arm you kind of create
her as to what looks good for you you
take her out you get the all of the
compliments that's your woman she's
amazing but i think as a woman i just
think
i don't know i feel like it works but
like what she said i just feel like the
age i'm at we should both be
a prize to each other like there should
be some middle ground or i can't expect
the man to do everything same way he i'm
very traditional but we have to adapt to
the
to the world that we're in if that makes
sense so i think if you just want me to
say yes or no i would say women are the
prizes from a young age you're cute your
hair's long you're this you're that
however i think as you grow up you
realize morals values like
integrity even beliefs like
you get it i feel like those things are
all things that intertwine and would
defend will determine if you're a prize
if you're some people are beautiful but
then that's the inside so i have a
question you said you're traditional how
are you traditional if you're not
married
because then you wouldn't you have
traditional outcomes
well me personally
i think i'm traditional in terms of my
morals and my beliefs in regards to men
and women so when i say i think i've
watched your podcast before you were
talking about submission i know this
generation auntie sub nature yeah
yeah but i believe we're in a world
where men and women are not equal yes we
should be ideally not
and i think that as you get older you
just need to understand yourself i'm not
gonna go in and project myself onto
someone's son i need to have my stuff
together whether it's psychologically
spiritually financially in check and
then we can do it together i don't think
there's a time form or you could also be
traditional get married and then get
divorced so at the end of the day i just
think well i would say if i got divorced
i wouldn't be traditional then like
because to me
like a traditional traditional outcome
so you're married with kids like i don't
think you can say you're traditional
that's the end goal 100 yeah but i'm
saying like until you have traditional
outcomes how can someone claim to be
traditional fair enough you know i mean
i'm not saying i'm traditional either
like i'm not
okay
i sorry i i believe that
in the beginning the woman is the price
so as in
in a woman a woman has her prime stage
and then when she gets to a certain
stage in her life
it switches over and the man becomes the
prize so like when women become
um
like i'd say from about 40
onwards okay
when the sexual marriage yeah it
switches over and the men become the
prize and the women are not so much the
price
okay what do you guys think men or women
i think men are the prizes i'm not gonna
lie
i'll be honest at all stages you think
men in the press
pretty much
not even in a way like to say oh i'm 100
let me say why yeah because as a guy
right now
at my age and even in all of our ages
especially like us guys in our 20s
i don't feel like there's
what pride like what do i get from being
in a relationship right now for me
personally in this current market right
now if i go out with a girl she's going
to get dates she's going to get driven
around wherever she's going to go on
holidays what do i get
what kind of woman are you looking for
yeah no but okay
yeah i just want to speak what can he
get that he can't get from a hooker and
a maid love yeah but
love what is it what is it what does
that mean
because a lot of times when i ask girls
if they give like broad statements
without specifics so could i could i
have something specific yeah um
so you're saying that you're gonna date
her take her on holidays i mean are
stupid generally generally yeah
good stuff yeah generally here there's
no woman on this planet that would get
all that good stuff and not give you
love
i think amber heard nothing
jada pinkett smith
there are women who are opportunists
there are women who see that he is the
prize and don't go for it but i'm saying
well but the thing is like what i'm
saying today like modern women i i think
it's a bad deal
yeah because we're not we're not virgins
anymore
like except september he found one
guys question was you a virgin when you
married your wife no okay the average
age of first marriage in the uk is 31 so
we don't have the youth anymore
and the purity so like what what do they
get so i think you guys get the better
end of the stick which is what makes us
surprised we're going i was going to say
all right you're saying the hooker all
of that in my in my mind yeah yeah apart
from sex all of that yeah in my head i
feel like you would have um you know
women are nurturing well most women
hopefully you would have that like i'm
talking whether it's
um psychological you know you have
people that are your friends before you
get into relationships that friendship
that whole like being there for you ever
is for a mental breakdown that sincerity
of not using you for what you have i
feel like that is what you potentially
would get from a sincere person if you
get what i'm saying so i'll get it from
a friend or like my guy friends
but i'm saying what i'm saying like
that's a woman's point of view because i
think that's what you would want is like
sincerity from a guy but like so a lot
of times like what as girls when we
think about what we want like we
projected under what guys want
they just they kind of just want us to
shut up
you know i think most
i think for most men so like the average
men
um i think women are the prize because
supposedly a lot of men
don't get women so yeah i think women
will be depressed however i think
the highest or like the most optimal
price would be a man because
most
like they they tend to
skew the market a bit more because like
like kevin samuels is his like version
of a high value man or what have you
they seem to be the biggest prize that
you could possibly get in dating however
i think for most men
women are surprised because they don't
get women anyway does that make sense
well wouldn't you say those guys don't
ever get a woman like because one out of
three men are virgins or haven't had sex
in the past year yeah so that's why i
would say like if yeah if those type of
guys got a woman they would feel like
they got a prize yeah but i don't really
think they ever get into relationships
like to me it's like there's there's two
types of guys there's a guy that's
always getting girls and then there's
the second one that gets their leftovers
at 30.
i think also it's about confidence from
the man's perspective i think a lot of
men in this society are not empowered
and given confidence to step forth as
men they're kind of bad they're battened
down to the female perspective of you
know i feel
and because i feel this you must
basically
accommodate those feelings and so
so sorry finish this what you're saying
men were allowed to have the confidence
as men in their masculinity there would
be more space for them to actually
pursue women a lot of men don't know how
to talk to women they don't know how to
approach women because everything's
offensive oh you know why are you
looking at me well you dress a certain
way i want to look nice i want guys to
look at me when the guy looks at you why
are you looking at me you get what i
mean so how are men supposed to feel
confident when 80 when women find 80 of
men is unattractive not okay or whatever
they they literally think they're
unattractive and then there's another
ten percent that they find uh okay maybe
here or they're in the last ten percent
that they'd go
well it's not first of all biology
natural selection the problem yeah but
like if how would you feel if they found
80 of women unattractive it'd be kind of
hard to you know feel confident in
yourself
i guess if you have externalized where
your confidence comes from i think when
you build confidence within yourself and
you know who you are then you step out
into the world as a confident man eg
i'll give you example and
let's say
i don't like to give this example box
for example future
to me he's not a confident man but he
projects confidence into the space where
women will be like oh he's got money you
sure he's made some bold moves yeah yeah
he's some bald man yeah you have to be
confident to produce confidence huh like
what do you have to be confident to
project confidence not necessarily no no
because you can have loads to some
degree at all no no no you can use that
you so projecting confidence to attract
women's attention and actually getting
women are two different things yeah but
what is self-esteem self-esteem doesn't
exist
what do you mean like there's no way to
measure it there's no like self-esteem
isn't real it's just like a thing that
the left says
well
it is
no there's no there's no statistical way
to measure self-esteem
okay there's no way to measure
self-esteem but there's a way to
measures measure our behaviors right
okay and behaviors coming from men with
low self-esteem eg we call them simps we
call them all kind of funny names now if
you're in the arena where women are
dominant and they're allowed to say and
do as they wish which we have right now
we have platforms social media etc
a lot of men will shy away from their
true self just to appease the women in
the arena because i agree as a man you
want women to attract to you the natural
thing it's a biological thing you know
what i mean so
a lot of guys don't have they don't know
how to talk to women i've experienced it
and i i've seen it but i think it's hard
for men because when you think about it
like they're they're told if they
approach a girl the wrong way they can
their girl can cry s-a
yeah and so how are they gonna be
confident when they're told many men
ain't [ __ ] from the time they're 12.
how did the other men do it how did the
confident men do it well because because
um we have a smaller and smaller
percentage of men screwing all the girls
so again women find 80 of men as
unattractive and they only swipe right
five percent of the time on dating apps
so the reason the dating markets kind of
f'd up right now is because four girls
that are fours five six and sevens are
sleeping with the eights nines and tens
and they think they're on that level and
they're not and they're rejecting the
guys that are on their level because a
guy is willing to sleep with anyone
right so but that doesn't mean that
doesn't that doesn't mean you're that
hot what's happening
that's the difference
you need to add to that as well you have
to remember that women are also breaking
up the homes so the men that would that
would traditionally raise other men to
become men are no longer there because
as we know about 80 to 90 of women did
leave or divorce their husband for
the primary reason being financial
reasons and the second being um
infidelity but infidelity doesn't matter
because we cheat at similar rates so
most women are leaving the men because
of financial reasons and then these men
are now raised by women and then they
try to chase women but women don't know
how to call women so then these men are
left thinking okay my mom told me to be
nice and buy her flowers and then she
looks and then she he tries to do that
for the girl she's like look at his
waist man
yeah
oh and and how are they supposed to feel
confident if they didn't have a man to
like raise them i agree with that
i agree with you i do agree with you as
you know when it comes to masculine
confidence it's best it comes from a man
be it your dad be your uncle whoever's
available to you and as a woman who has
had a strong relationship with her dad
it makes you a different type of woman
on the market you have a different level
of confidence you have realistic more
realistic expectations towards men and
you know there's certain things that my
dad helped me understand as a woman i'm
i'm more forgiving than women in my age
group when it comes to not forgiving
that's the wrong word but
i have a better understanding of the
hardships that men face and i have a bit
more empathy towards their position do
you know what i mean but at the same
time having that understanding with uh a
group of men who haven't had that
nurturing is still very difficult i've
got a question for you then
would you date a simp
wouldn't have the confidence to approach
me oh yeah
you're sympathetic of their position and
obviously you're being raised by your
father that's had influence on you so
would you date a sim
being sympathetic
well
first of all in my opinion a simple is
not a man it's a it's a tiger
wow no no he's not a man in my opinion
like if you don't have a diary
oh sorry
if you don't have certain attributes
then you're not on my radar so for
example i'm not a materialistic person i
don't look for someone with nice clothes
nice things blah blah but i do look for
a man who has logic direction knows how
so is your answer no yes no i wouldn't
they assume
right but like if you're sympathetic to
the plight of mine i didn't say
sympathetic i said empathy empathetic
okay i'm pathetic why wouldn't you date
a sub
yeah i wouldn't there's no there's no
compatibility there for me i know that a
man with logic provisions knows what
he's about would fit better with me so
that's why
so um question do you guys think that
women date up or down
up up up i think depending on age
okay so then then what do you say up i
say would you guys say up oh yeah
so how can we say women are the prize if
they date up and men date down that's a
good question that's a great question
you know that's an amazing question i
feel like the generation we're in now
uh-huh i feel like everybody just has to
date up because no no everybody can't
know so so
i'm just kind of up somewhat someone's
reaching every relationship someone
likes the other more exactly someone's
reaching someone's settlement yeah okay
personally i genuinely feel like where
we are in this life here
everything is so difficult yeah
everything is getting worse and western
it's not check your friend zone
wow that was a good one it's not yeah
but i feel like a lot of my guy friends
we're compatible as friends and i'm not
and i don't want to lose that no no no
you you're not attracted to them like
that or something you like the attention
definitely attracted to some of my guy
friends i just wouldn't want to go there
would they want to go there with you
possibly
possibly however i just know that the
boundaries and i'd rather i treasure the
friendship i'm not trying to do that
yeah because more time if a relationship
ends up bad i've lost you as a friend
yeah and as that and if i value the
friendship i feel like but it can end up
good
what the relationship happens
that's the risk in it it sounds quite
pessimistic
do you really see yourself having a lot
of male friends once you get married
does that really help no no yeah so
healthy that's not healthy that's not
all that's so it might end anyways
so what's the point of having them
around no but i just feel like i'd like
in this day and age like you have i feel
like a lot of people are mad
so what do you what do you what do you
see as the problems in the dating market
the problems in the data market i feel
like um everything has become so what
can i get what can i get materialistic
and i feel like people aren't looking at
character anymore do you think that's
the manner of the women i think it's
both do you think it's the matter
also the women i feel like women
have become this which means that the
men don't even care anymore it's like if
you want me for maybe materialistic
things
quite a few women so it's kind of like
if that's all you look at me for then
all right cool i'll take you your sister
your auntie and then
could you explain that more what do you
mean by that what i mean by that is
there's a lot of guys who let's say
faithfulness was something that let's
say ten years ago was key right now in
this generation it's like nobody cares
or quite a few people don't care if the
guy is faithful as long as he's looking
after them so you've got a lot of men
who maybe they were faithful growing up
now it's like i don't even need to be
afraid because i can get the test
is that the fault of the men or the
women i'm saying support of the woman
yeah yeah i agree with oh yeah sorry i
genuinely believe it's the fault of the
woman because it's like if you hand them
a silver platter why would they not take
it
yeah and why do i need to be faithful um
um spiritual distance yeah if you're not
even required so why did you say women
are the prize then because i feel like
when you're growing up like i said from
a young age you're pretty sure that i
think when you get to a certain age you
need to understand you need to
understand the flower of your youth
when it's finished darling i understand
it's finished however i feel like um
naturally it's you're taught today up
because i just feel like
he just needs to be the head of the
household if that makes sense so the
head would mean he's up yeah so then he
would be the price yeah but that's what
i'm saying my answer was when you get to
a certain age i feel like it flips
me okay i think let's say 25 and up 25
and 25
i think off the high school probably no
i agree with you what what do you think
i i think i think men are always the
prize because because the women the
women that men want like
women 50 of women that hit 30 are single
and childless
so so the most do you think men
understand they're the prize for the
young i think i think the small
percentage of men do when they have when
they have at their doorstep
like from from the time they're from the
time they're
kid you know because it's only a very
small percentage of men that get that
and then you know the the women
like the women that
won't settle and i think they're just
going to die alone
no seriously because yeah and they won't
have kids and but fulfill their
biological imperative so you have to
compromise right yeah yeah i mean
something willing to though yeah but
this is the thing like we compromise
where it always benefits us and never
benefits the man because when we
compromise it's like at 30.
and that's not what men want
[Music]
when you talk about the dating market
they all do all the women on the panel
believe that women are the problem in
the with the data market
they contribute they contribute hundred
percent they contribute because there's
one can i just say this yeah there's
more women on the market
in the daisy market and how i would put
is everyone so a lot of women say
they're the prize but they don't act
like a prize so they're readily
available if you're available to 25 men
how are your prize you're readily
available i put it like this if you have
a rolex they don't advertise rolex you
know the value of it
if you see a ferrari they don't
advertise that you know the value of it
if you're on socials dating apps
advertising yourself with no clothes
you know trying to get mail attention
are you really a prize what that sounds
like to me
that sounds like a cognitive dissonance
to me so like you think one thing but
you're not the other so that still goes
back to the fact that women are
potentially the problem in the data
market because of this delusion that
they they carry i'm the prize yeah i
deserve this and i deserve that yeah
really i'm not actually the prize so
thank you
like how can you be a prize at all if
you're a virgin if you're not a virgin
in the 1950s like like you were a hoe if
you if you slept with like two people i
think men nowadays would pray for two
and so it's like like what how are you a
prize if you're not a virgin so you're
well first of all sorry
the social parameters have changed okay
we know this and we're acknowledging
that's the case here in this but men
haven't changed just because the social
parameters have changed but the thing is
the social the social parameters have
changed to appease women yeah and so so
me but men have remained the same they
they want the same things women have
changed no but
as i said the social parameters have
changed so the social parameters for men
have changed and the social parameters
for women have changed what do you mean
what do you define social parameters so
for example
materialistically
men are supposed to still provide
be able to provide a higher rate and a
faster rate from a younger age
this is a social parameter change it's
not realistic it is set out by women i
agree but with the women with the ladies
now a lot of us we have a materialistic
approach to how we view men and when
they can't provide that we get upset we
don't actually look at like what you
said the characteristics the moralistic
values we don't look at actually when i
look at this man do i see family because
a lot of people they're they want
uh
financial benefits but they don't
actually want family what does it make
women the problem then yeah
because men are the same like if
anything more is expected of men is less
is given to them
i think that um we're getting married a
lot later in life and that's
you know part of it so like for example
maybe
50 years ago getting married at age 16
to 18 might not have been a big deal
whereas now when uh when a
a young woman wants to get married at 21
it's like are you ready for this you
know have you finished uni yeah have you
traveled
there's so much that women are doing
that they weren't doing 50 years ago
that they're doing now and it's it's
affecting
the the age that people get married so
that's going to make women a problem
i never said women
but then
did you not say that they were the prize
i said we're the prizes when we're
younger oh yeah yeah before 40.
and i'm curious i haven't heard much
from you what do you think because i
don't agree okay i feel like remember
that's a problem okay oh great tell me
why tell me why because
i'm young isn't it so
i'm just thinking when i was younger
women were always the one
um more involved in the relationships
men were always the one cheating
treating the women wrong so that now i'm
21. all of us are tired at the age of
20. why did you pick him
um
if you if you if women hate being
cheated on why'd you pick the ones that
cheat girls know you know early on that
they're going to cheat on you you know
you know damn well you know you know you
know
you know damn well you know damn well
that that guy is capable of cheating so
how that's how is that on him when you
picked him you know what
after i finished with the guys that
cheat i was not like let me go to a nice
guy even now but now you're left over
for him oh
but i was only like 18. so yeah look at
i'm not i'm not saying i'm just saying
that's how men view it
18. yeah i mean i mean
i don't i don't know i'm not going to
ask like what
i'm just saying like i'm saying this is
common so so you're young but i'm saying
this is common where girls will go
through the bad boys and the cheaters
until they're 27 28. and then come to
the nice guys who they've been rejecting
the last decade right and saying take me
oh i'm ready for you and they're like
well
now you're you're chad's leftovers
and i say that but it's like how is that
on them when we pick them because one
out of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the last year so
there's a lot of men that won't cheat on
you you just don't want them
look at your friend zone or go to go to
you guys don't have time do you guys
have taco bell here you do
go to go to taco bell ask the guy out
behind the counter i bet you he
you know how we're talking about the
whole don't we feel like back in the day
there was no social media like they were
writing letters everyone's covered up
from head to toe i feel like because now
there's more temptation even further
guys because women because women because
yeah because women got worse yeah
because because men will do anything to
get laid
literally literally anything so if
if we required marriage to get laid we
would all be married
if we if we required a fancy date values
of lesson that's what you're saying
i would say women have thrown it at them
yeah like we're less valuable to men
because men are the same
can we ask them in that what's valuable
to them that would be yeah go ahead
start with them
like what do you mean like
what what does value mean to you in a
woman
uh femininity
uh submission
um
being my piece
that's the key one yeah that's important
so important he loved that one yeah
that's it yeah i would say literally the
same stuff as him but literally the same
um being feminine
peace of mind um being able to look at
yourself as well and have
self-development like be able to
actually say accountability yeah you
know what i mean and being able to have
a conversation about stuff like if
there's an issue which some a lot of
people can't do to be honest so also
question do you guys value purity
would you guys would you guys rather
have a girl that slept with 100 guys or
one guy
okay
i'm not even talking to you okay okay
i'm talking to you okay let's let's say
would you rather have a girl that slept
with 10 guys or 50.
10. okay okay so you value purity yeah
yeah definitely okay yeah
same thing yeah yeah okay what about you
same as me boy
you know what's crazy um that you're
talking about period i went into
someone's tick tock live but it's about
purely and she was talking about andrew
tate and you know he said the same kind
of thing yeah with girls sleeping with
loads of people and the girl's sleeping
with less um and she said well i don't
really care what guys think i'll sleep
with whoever i want and as much people
as i wanted nothing you could do about
it
in my head i just thought
this is the problem because i don't know
if there's like something
but they will still get laughed so
yeah
but though no i don't agree with it i
don't agree with that well i think
that's where we tapped but that's crazy
but those kind of girls
but those kind of girls i feel like i
strongly disagree it's mad because you
get like let's say i've seen good guys
that will go for that and i'm just there
like what i'll tell you whether the nice
guy is picking up the leftovers and the
problem is those girls don't respect him
because they actually want the dude that
she did whenever whenever a girl
whenever a girl has a guy that she
always complains about that's who she
loved the most
it's not it's not the one that she
doesn't really talk about he said he was
such a good boyfriend she didn't like
him
you're laughing you know it's true
and so those guys pick them up at 30 and
then they'll still cheat with the
the guy they really wanted
or wish they were with him yeah what
dumbful
that's why that's why like virgins
should be preferred like if you if you
slept with one person and you get
married what is your chance of a happy
marriage do you think
i heard your podcast you actually
mentioned this and you said all the time
but then do you know what i find crazy
that you also get the guys that complain
that oh my day she didn't know what she
was doing in bed and then now he started
cheating five years down the line
because she's so dead and also no wait
no wait no wait no i've heard a guy say
we actually weren't sexually compatible
that's the reason why because he was
probably too much of a freak most girls
can't have good sex seriously
most girls are not good at six how do
you know ah
[Laughter]
ding ding ding
no honestly most girls just take wood
let's be real like what if it's your
partner would you not teach them and
would you not
would you like not like grow like as in
you're teaching her what you like she's
teaching you what she likes of course
it's contextual um i don't think you can
be the partner and not expect her to
like certain things but that's what i'm
saying certain guys they're just overly
freaky because most men are very simple
to please just blow
straight
but
but guys would prefer a girl they could
teach versus because if she's coming in
a freak he's like where did you learn
from
where is you where are you
i i i was so funny i have this
discussion without my mo cousins my
brothers i feel like every guy says
listen i've been red men are for most
women are from venus one of my favorite
books men are so simple well what you
lost say peace of mind when they don't
want to talk just leave them he will
come back when he's ready and i feel
like because we're so emotional and
erratic sometimes it's like you know how
men are quite logical when you call your
man of a problem we just want to hear
is it is it is that the reality most
times we're not doing well because of
our nature we don't we try in our heads
we're like like me for example
i feel like i can be very peaceful i can
be very understanding
but there are times in the month where
i'm not it's i'm just not having it
because of my i don't know maybe i can
blame it on the hormones or or that day
is just not the day or i'm in my head
about something that he's done
as much as i want to be peaceful i might
not be peaceful that day and so i feel
like somebody wouldn't be your character
no i'm not i won't be peaceful i'm not
saying that it's it's good that i'm like
that i know that it can be a problem but
relationships are never perfect i mean i
could control that at work right i i can
and the thing is i do control it in my
relationship as much as i can there's no
relationship that doesn't have fights or
arguments you know what i mean so but
sometimes you go from zero to 100 and
you know you've as long as you
acknowledge you've done it and you're
able to apologize and accept
accountability and try and change that's
just quite interesting though because
like um phil said you can eat for most
women you can stay quiet at work but at
home you're letting loose like why is
that
i mean you have to communicate with
someone
why does your boss have more power than
you it depends on what you call it in
new some women are mad and it's shouting
and it's throwing plates
i mean we see it on social media we see
movies and stuff like you know some
women do throw things around and then
jordans
smashing phones smashing cars we see
that yeah
but
a lot of women are not doing that and
also can i say something before you've
got with that women i'm gonna lie you
should have seen her in all her seasons
when i say seasons i mean how she's
reacting to like how she's talking when
she don't know that you're watching how
she's dealing with certain situations i
understand some women are tapped some
men are attacked but i also feel like if
you're getting with a woman you should
try and see her you won't always see it
though you you won't even i think i
agree i feel like you can see everyone
in their seasons you just have to
i think in modern generation a lot of us
lack self-awareness 100 yeah so
and i think that is more um
more women like self-awareness for that
i'm gonna say that just because
of the situation we're talking about how
prevalent are they you don't really see
men going out there and doing mad stuff
like that you see women doing that more
so
i speak on it if you disagree i agree
with you i mean it's shown it's shown
and that's what i was going to say it's
promoted to perpetuate to perpetuate it
further and to empower people who don't
have
the understanding so for me
it's not about me but being
self-reflective is a part of day-to-day
life as a partner to somebody else if
you can't reflect on your own behaviors
you shouldn't be on in a relationship
what do you mean by self-reflective what
actionable items is that so if for
example you have a disagreement with
your partner okay
you should be able to communicate how
how that came about
what
because men they use less words yeah
they don't want to hear a whole load of
talking let's be honest they just want
to get straight to the point
what can i do to be a better partner to
you in this situation communicating that
to your partner because you're the
you're the second in command if you want
to say
your your man is a representation of you
and you are a representation of your man
when he's not around
and when he's around obviously
do you think that's what men want well i
don't know do you think they want like
constant communication or do you think
they want to shut up
what i will say i don't know what men
want but i will ask them i don't assume
anything i'm going to ask you every man
every man is different what say for
example what devontae requires and
what's your name so yeah
oh sorry sorry phil phil what phil
requires maybe totally different
spectrums you know
phil's married to his wife she's got
maybe not i don't know but maybe she's
got
six attributes of maybe the ten
attributes he really loves and that is
good enough and he can work on that but
if you don't if you're not
self-reflective as a as a woman and a
man together
i think i think women don't have to be
self-aware though in today's society
because
because because of the accountability
element so yeah there is no impetus
throughout your life as you're growing
older for you to have to be
self-reflective and self-aware because
especially if you're attracted
especially if you're attractive most men
give you everything you want you can get
there's no need there's no need for you
to have to think okay how do i behave in
this context of that context that's your
fault i think that comes with maturity
given example i was talking to a girl
and she's very attractive and i told her
most of the girls around you are with
you because you're pretty and most of
the guys that chat to you just want to
[ __ ] you but to her she just thought
this is all everybody loves me everybody
loves me so at what point in her life
does she realize that she's being used
and by the time she's able to realize by
when she's mature she's already beat out
by bear man so where's her valley at
that time
why do why do women always think they're
tense
do they
constantly
i do i do street interviews all the time
girls will say i'm a tan i'm
i've never in my life had a man say i'm
a 10. you know when i'm honest i feel
like if my like if i don't look nice my
guy friend will say you don't look nice
like change that i get oh girl you look
so cute so i feel like men accept the
reality and they're not going to lie to
you
you might not you sorry person x might
be really
minus one however her girlfriends
because of mental health and like a lot
of things they might just be like you're
really beautiful right but that goes
that goes back to the point that women
don't face reality i feel like the women
who say that they're tense don't really
believe they are anyway
when you when you see how they behave
they don't behave like they believe
they're tense they're just saying it
because of what they can get but the
point is they can go out in society and
be delusional yeah and that's that's
normal for women and women women are
built out of every single bad decision
we make can i just
can i just say about the 10 business
most of the women that lie to their
friends and say their friend is a 10
know when she's afraid
sorry
that happens because it allows those
women who also feel that they're a free
and a four yeah or maybe a five or a six
feel bolstered up in that group do you
understand feel like the beautiful
friend like oh yeah girl you look good
but when you go out like your friends
looking a bit tacky and you feel a bit
more attractive
that's a dynamic in in play so they're
more desirable to men it's indirect is
it insulting for a woman to be called
average
i think
if it's the reality it's the reaction
honestly if you're average your
personality might be like out of this
world but the reality is to the human
eye or to whoever is telling you you are
average that's their opinion i don't
think there's any problem with
preference you might be um like 10 out
of 10 to me you might be 5 out of 10
someone else it's just and you can't but
that's a female like you're not a 10 out
of 10 to anyone if you're average
talking but then you can't take what
someone else is saying if you are
average you know you're average go and
work on yourself or believe in your
average and not be that right
but i'm saying most people are average
so like oftentimes if i tell a girl
she's average they they get defensively
mad because it has a negative
connotation but just tell them fix up
and use your brain
what is a three what's a ten that's
clarified that's nice okay ken's perfect
okay
what are the what are the things that
make people these rings look that's what
i was talking about like women's primary
value to the world is your looks that's
the most like valuable asset that you
can see every year when they show the
most handsome man exactly
and i'll just be like he's alright i
don't think he's all that but
scientifically when you go out and ask
people yeah because you find because you
find 80 percent of men unattractive
that's why you think that no i think
that's not right it's just not my type i
know but that's right that's why like
that's why you could find the most
handsome man on the planet
no i'm sorry i'm so late you keep
interrupting me
stop and you could find a guy in the top
five percent of of male handsome and you
still find him yeah he's all right
and like that's that's that's women
that's true women do we do let's be real
we do it no but i think someone's so
nice and she might do even when you see
someone with their boyfriend you'll be
like
i'll tell him he's nice no no no no no
you see someone with their boyfriend so
you don't have the boyfriend's mind no
i'm saying if i think someone's nice i
believe no no if you don't think
someone's boyfriend is
the nice what's your reaction
at least he treats you nice
to answer your question i i say eight to
ten means you can get a modeling
contract eight you're the prettiest girl
in a small town nine means you're going
to hollywood based on your looks alone
10 is damn near perfect seven i go off
of kevin samuels scale so i don't do
sevens because people are either models
or they're cute pretty five is normal
six is cute below that
okay
but yeah that's that's how so but a lot
like on tick tock the other day
um
i i got banned but before i got banned i
commented on a girl because she was
going off on my things and i just said
another average looking girl coping oh
man because she was
because she was mad because i was saying
men prefer younger women it's just true
it's not fun i don't enjoy that i'm
getting you know i'm 25 i'm gonna be 26
in november i don't enjoy that but it's
just true
and if you're average looking at 30
you're below average
but you know she
but like that's in it but do you see
everyone silent because that's an insult
but it shouldn't be it's not it wasn't
because the insult is
it's so crazy because it's like men want
maybe what's younger than them maybe
because
you're bendable you're movable it's that
you're teachable whereas when you're
older you're probably more stuck in your
ways and also you're probably prettier
because you're younger unless you just
don't look your age
that shouldn't be the case however
people do lie because
if if you walk around you believe you're
10 and you're like i'm a 10 i'm a 10.
people are gonna shut you down and say
no you're not but if you go around
saying i'm a two that would also try and
pump you up and say no you're not even a
two you're five and it's true most
people don't wanna be honest about what
they really think because they don't
want to hurt feelings yeah but why would
you understand that but i think if women
really got that pushback there wouldn't
be so many claiming their times
true i don't think i think women but if
a man goes on social media and he says
i'm a town i'm a town town i swear to
god women will be the first ones even
even you this is the most handsome man
on the planet
for a magazine
let me finish
and your first comment isn't it he's all
right
it's i'm no hate to you it's just part
of like women but my thing is we're not
all going to think attractive is
attractive that's my point do you know
what i think it is as well some more for
women's i i thought for me let me speak
for myself like when when i'm if i see a
man and i don't think he's attractive or
my type
my mind could change when i start
talking to him or when i get to know him
or see his vibe so i think sometimes
because women don't see looks first if
he's feminine like he starts talking
like a girl and he don't like women
sorry
i don't like women if he's talking to me
if you ever had a guy that was very
attractive then he opened his mouth and
he like sounds like a girl and his voice
is so high pitched and you're like oh
god
i'll assume he's a
i can't say it
um
okay so if so going back to the prize
analogy
if women date up
and they claim they're the prize
and she is the prize in a relationship
then isn't that relationship destined to
fail
see if i can say that again sorry so if
women if women claims that she's the
prize isn't that relationship destined
to fail because women date up
i don't want to speak first because okay
i don't wanna you you're quiet i feel
like you you gotta yeah yeah i'm i'm
thinking
i'm not sure
i just think the man is the head i feel
like the man is the head the woman is
the neck we all work
as one so women don't actually know how
much power they have in regards to
like you could get a man to do something
just by maybe advising or changing the
way you speak and it can be done so if
we're going technically i would say yeah
because for her to be
what was the context of of the prize so
if she thinks she's the prize already
i already think that we need to
understand that the man
you see the word prize is a bit have you
okay have you ever seen a girl that like
genuinely feels like she married down
oh and like like that she she runs the
show she has her husband by the way it's
like she she walks all over does that
does that's like horrible to see i don't
like that because i feel like the man
like he's just
disrespectful when he when he puts her
on a pedestal yeah like will smith
remember a couple i called i called will
smith before any when he was
remember at all the awards show girls
don't like that they don't respect that
but in that relationship she she he felt
like she was the prize
and now and now you have
one of the a guy in the top one percent
of looks money
i think it used to be muscles
sorry but like
looking stupid he looks like a fool
because of his woman the whole like that
relationship has failed then
100 oh yeah
you jaded and you're saying that's
because she because he looked at jada as
the press
she gave her the controller well
partially yeah because she like jada
jada wanted to be with the tupac
and then and so and that's what that's
what that's when we go back to the bad
boys and the nice guys well because he
picked a girl he picked a girl that had
been ran through but by tupac yeah maybe
he wants to do that
he got tupac's leftovers
go ahead so i think you mentioned
something where you said um
it was along the lines of you guys have
basically gassed up the girl
to make it like you said she thinks
people like her but they don't it's just
her looks so therefore you guys have
played that well but i was also going to
say you know how the women the term
women are mad
i think we are
visibly
more mad because we act out i also think
there are some guys whether it's
narcissistic tendencies or
psychologically they may and it's not
seen on social media or it's not seen
out that all we see is the woman going
mad the woman burning shoes the woman
doing this but i feel like sometimes you
get a lot of mad men who's true i don't
know what they studied but they get into
a woman's head and it may not be like
she's
actively doing something but those men
were raised by women
i'll tell you that now those men were
raised by men what those tendencies
you're talking about the acts of
manipulation against your head and
that's what women do that's what we do
to their husbands that's what we do when
they have kids
that's women so the men you're talking
about goes back to women angry women
clarify
and at the end of the day women are in
control of relationships i know men get
to pick who they're in a relationship
with but you could argue that women are
in control because we're in control of
sex and these days that seems to come
first
so we're picking so if we we hate the
toxic and we hate the manipulative guys
why are we sleeping with them
and then creating more by having babies
and not staying with the guy i think can
i just add to this conversation so for
me i don't we use this term toxic
masculinity i don't believe that you can
be masculine and be toxic you're either
toxic and you're not serving your
purpose so you're not a man
um i don't i don't know if you would
agree i don't think toxic masculinity is
a real thing i think that's what i'm
saying yeah i don't think that's a real
thing it's not you can't be
masculine and be toxic you're just not
masculine so if you have toxic traits
when you look back at people these men
who are on social media shouting
carrying on a certain way feeding into a
certain type of dynamic
these are the same women that flock to
those same men and we have to ask
ourselves why are we why are we flocking
to them is it because we see a
similarity but sorry um because women
love drama no no but that's what i was
about to say do we see the similarity
between ourselves and that man if it's a
feminine trait it is a feminine trait so
no women love drama no no that's why
yeah women love drama a lot of women
love drama because
because it feeds into their emotional
need
don't women watch the nba why don't
women watch the nba where a team is
coming together and they but they watch
the kardashians
[Music]
or the bachelor but also
wait it's not all but but i'm saying
generally speaking women women yeah
women like drama generally speaking when
it fee first of all i can say they
wouldn't watch the mba because it
doesn't feed into their validation
circuit second of all it doesn't feed
into their emotional circumstances
so
yeah
so with the kardashians i've never
watched them so i don't really know but
i will say it is tailored to appeal to
women to validate their need to have
superficial am i talking so much about
superficial gains and having the higher
value man that they deserve you you know
look at the social circles that we're in
it's very messy because of where we are
in the social classes
if you look at people with more body
they know how to cover their their stuff
up they know how to okay i'm gonna mess
around over here but when i turn 30 or
35 i'm gonna marry a woman who's in my
social class we're gonna have our stuff
together and we're gonna have kids if
we're gonna have a family i might take
coke in the back or i might do my thing
no no this is real life when you're in a
class a lower class like myself everyone
here working class we're messy
we don't we jump from this to that to
that and whatever we can get it's a free
for all
i was going to say
i partially agree what she's saying
because let's say i've had friends maybe
in a higher social class you realize
that they really cover each other yeah
and i've realized whether it's illegal
whether it's not legal whether it's
drugs whether it's sex even with like
the whole do you mean cover each other
so as in let's say there's a scandal
okay there's we're going to sign an nda
and we're going to keep this between us
it's not going to go anywhere it's
covered whereas i get what she's saying
but why is hollywood so messy
but it comes it's entertainment it's
money like i feel like hollywood is not
a real place i feel like it's just it's
it's drama literally it's make-believe
and it's drama i feel like when you go
into the real world and you start
meeting real people those classes
someone's son has knocked over someone
attempted no this is it
yeah and it's so crazy because i feel
like as people you need to understand
and try and delve into different social
classes to understand that stop staying
where you are that's how you're doing
but the point is that women in general
like drama yeah yeah i agree with that
yeah but if
it feeds into emotional needs
but it doesn't matter like like where
who cares why we just do one one
is attention women love attention let's
get it right attention we love it
um
different varies from woman to woman me
personally i can do about it probably
the ladies who could agree limited
attention we don't need that whole
spotlight um and then the validation
that is that's what carries it if you're
getting validated by 300 girls on social
media talking about i i love you you're
right you should do this you should it
doesn't happen for men though i'm saying
like average no average look they've
done studies average looking girls get
more messages than top ten percent guys
yeah the question for the girls quickly
yeah so i think you agreed that um less
attention would be good right
the age i'm at yeah yeah i know so would
you stop wearing makeup and do not
yourself okay so i've i'm good so just a
bit backstory i was a tomboy up until
very recently i just about learned how
to do makeup the other day i think it's
just about i i'm i can go out
confidently if i wear makeup i prefer
not to where it's very annoying unless
there's a special occasion i might wait
but that's what i'm saying there's a
minority then there's generalism i
personally i don't like it i just feel
like
do you guys have instagram yeah so like
so how can you say you hate attention if
you've instagram so all of my socials
aren't private and okay and and i would
tell i told people this i know everybody
on my social media as in whether it's
secondary school i'm not posting for
clarification if my thing will be open
if i wanted i'm posting for maybe family
updates or because i like traveling i'm
showing what i'm doing so that's what
i'm saying i might be the minority but i
get it but even on a small even on a
small scale though you're still looking
for attention in some level yeah like i
mean i'm not saying i'm saying you're
not i'm not saying you're not you're not
to the level of like the girls posting
their ass on ig yeah i get it but like
yeah yeah but because even though i know
everyone you're right if you're on
holiday
i'll be like oh let's interact
what are you doing so i do agree with
that but i'm just very private that's me
as a person i just think everybody's
would you guys delete your insta for
your boyfriends no for my husband or my
boyfriend boyfriend
if my husband didn't want me to have
social media and he like we had a
conversation
i would first of all i need to
understand why and then i probably would
do it wait how could you be submissive
if you wouldn't delete your social media
for your because that's like my husband
telling me okay you're a bit um you're
an extrovert turn it down so where so so
where do you say is controlling and
where do you say it's um because maybe
it might not be
what i think is better
so say that then what would be a valid
reason for you okay so i've known
someone who their partner wasn't on
socials and but it was like she was a
bit out there so can you delete it i
think that's a genuinely good reason if
you're genuinely posting for your family
and friends it's not that you're doing
anything man he has access to your dms
or you look at each other's phones but
but if you don't if you don't care that
much about instagram then why would you
care to like because what it wouldn't
part of being submissive are you
deleting it
and my whole point is when is it
submissive and when and when is it
controlling because my thing is yes
there's no problem deleting it however
explain to me why if i'm not speaking to
anyone on there i update my family via
socials i see where my family are if
there's no valid reason and that's what
i'm saying submission yes you should
submit but i feel like when does it
become like he's controlling you
you get to pick so it's about picking a
leader that you trust
but you it has to be a guy that you
would trust enough that if he said
delete your instagram you know he's a
good man and he has a good reason for it
and a man like that would only ask you
to delete your instagram if he had a
good reason anyway i don't think
a manipulative man saying delete your
instagram i don't think he's a good man
i feel like instagram is quite shallow
it would have like
not like that but it would have to be
something something bigger like maybe
change what you're wearing as we're
going out because i feel like it's
sometimes so fickle it's not a big thing
to me
so why did you say no
um to to the attention question
yeah also the delete in my instagram
yeah because i post a lot on my
instagram my instagram gets me money um
so i'm not deleting what if he was
paying for the bills
oh yeah then i deleted
it
yeah okay i'm gonna take a second and
read super chats guys thank you so much
for all of the super chats today all
super chats are going towards the new
studio i think we're gonna move in like
two three weeks we'll get a place with
actual air conditioning so the guests
won't be sweating so much
um also guys like the video let's see
there's 3 000 people in here and we're
only at 900 likes come on let's get to 1
500 likes let's go okay
so sentience pearl please don't dissuade
them from being on ig and men love women
on there we can see the damage the price
the lack of morals and values we have a
permanent record of the used dubai
porta-potties to use and refuse thank
you for using ig
um reasoned and seasoned
try a not all jar well they have to put
a dollar in every time they say it
curious to how fast the tone shifts when
it comes to actually cost money to spout
bs mgtow by logic 2 tupac is still
winning
a dw man makes more than women it's
called dating women makes more than man
it's called dating down why i know why i
want to hear a different perspective
asani ali if a man is a cheater and has
three women it's because each one of
them has three attributes that the man
wants one might be friendly but ugly
another is submissive but can't cook or
clean etc mgtow by logic if you're the
prize then you'd be delivering used
goods
or then you'd be delivering the goods
but you don't women generally are bitter
angry loud masculine argumentative
greedy and wasteful liars
oh my gosh
matt butcher pearl please emphasis
emphasize a good a good attitude will
take a lady from a three to a nine
instantly
taylor grape i wouldn't go
you think a three to a nine yes
okay taylor graybill like the video fnf
will be on grilling in september and
invite them on um oh wait i lost my uh
the uk economist until they found out
their mate's boyfriend is a seven figure
earner but now he's a ten sick lid don't
blame your hormones blame the twinkies j
watt women can be a four with looks but
can be a seven or eight in a guy's mind
for just being respectful
eduardo hill hill brand i'm from brazil
so my english is not good but i want to
say this men do anything to get
so if a girl if a girl thinks that the
man is not good enough this is because a
miscommunication on what they want great
discussion alistar horton most women
think they are a 10 because of the simps
their ego is much like a balloon and
it's easy to over inflate and it only
takes one rp
or one prick to deflate it sentience
what a men value we value 304s a boss
babe strong independent attitude with
more bodies the annual abortion rate and
promiscuous we love them for one use
just never as wives because of your
physical and emotional trauma
lazy artist having a counter and the
having a counter in the upper right of
the screen to track how many times they
say i feel like would be a nice feature
for the show
grant r
when will pearly's channel have the
conversation that islam solves many of
the world's problems i'm a white
westerner and now a proud muslim when
white men discover islam like white
women discovered yoga in the 2000s it's
game over facts
wayne williams
the way women dress today is like having
an open bar an aaa meeting you can do it
but it's is it fair to the men around
you hot takes the whole situation is a
result of too many women getting
educated and they think it adds to their
smv but it does not mgtow by logic a
hundred dollar super chatter and clap
if you demand
if you demand men need to be better than
you have to deliver the goods to
otherwise it's entitlement deliver the
goods ladies and continue to do so till
the day you die or be alone there's no
free free ride you earn the best man you
can you don't get him earn him colton
lynch 50 super chat let's go okay um i i
am a six three lean 200 pound man who
works as a good job as a senior software
engineer i'm looking for a house i don't
drink and i can't seem to find a woman
with traditional values in my area jay i
think it's an interesting question is
who created simpson in cells men or
women thoughts oh that's i might come
back to that later the bikini bottom
band at 50 super chat
it's easy for women to say just be
confident when you're constantly it's
easy for women to say just be confident
when you're constantly getting gassed up
24 7 for simply existing like pearl said
80 or of 80 of men are unattractive to
women how am i supposed to be confident
when eight out of women think i'm
unattractive devon oaks told my girl of
two years that i was concerned about her
weight as a health concern based on her
family's history needless to say i'm
single now thoughts
peter b
self-esteem is self-value david
thornburn
do you think asian men are the least
desired in the dating scene if so why do
you think that is
nathaniel
nana ran joe how can people how can
women be the prize if they want a man
taller than them that makes more money
stronger than them more educated and in
better shape keys prime time how come
when women raider rate themselves it's
an 8 and up generally the answer is 10
but yet the majority of women use makeup
wigs and hair extensions to enhance
see cowie just sent to eddie's ig some
interesting info on the wage gap stats
for a uk for an eu country for the next
time it comes up anyways keep doing what
you're doing sme talks keep the
conversation going guys uh monkey useop
i'm not reading that i'm sorry i'm not
reading
um okay
so um
but okay um
i'm gonna ask the next question so
if a woman so going back to the prize
question
if a woman is the prize wouldn't that
make the man the simp
okay someone defines him for me like
putting a woman on a pedestal will smith
hmm
yeah
yeah it wouldn't make them it would make
a man a simple
so is there something wrong with a man
like admiring his woman yes because most
of the time the woman ends up like kind
of walking over him like jada and it
doesn't really work so so no one has a
good example of a man that does it
healthily now without i've never seen it
absolutely
jay-z
i think there's a difference between
admire it's it's like you can give an
admiration to a girl if she deserves it
but does did jada deserve the admiration
that she's gotten over the years when
she's been giving her kids letters from
tupac
that's crazy when she has her daughter
writing a letter to tupac about how much
her daughter misses him even though i
think she deserves she wasn't even alive
when too that's that's what i'm saying
but that's how crazy like jada is to the
family so do you don't you feel like
jade jade is on the mad end of the
spectrum
it's an example it's like okay when we
see some something happen to celebrities
it's indicative of a society for example
amber heard johnny depp that's extreme
right but if that happened to a man with
money power and privilege what happens
to the average guy so this is happening
to will smith on the big screen again
he's got money power and privilege who
has more leverage than will smith what
happens to the normal guy who's just
marrying the ran through girls someone's
got to do it i thought that like what he
said if there's a healthy type i don't
think there's anything wrong with
like a healthy if you deserve it but the
problem is modern women don't deserve it
because we have nothing that men want
anymore
for them for most average men they don't
know what the line of healthy admiration
is because in order to keep the woman
they think they just got to do
everything and just go to their beck and
call mm-hmm and we often find that
that's not attractive
so i think she'll find that twenty
percent elsewhere i think if it was
healthy he wouldn't be a simple yeah
okay so this thing means that it's an
unhealthy
if you had to crush yourself to please
somebody would you as a woman if you had
to crush yourself to please your man you
can identify that that is wrong right
that applies this way around depends
what do you mean by crush yourself so an
example
i see you looking over there but i say
you know with simpion
so as a simp you crush yourself you you
you crush who you are to satisfy the
woman that you're with right you put
this woman on a pedestal on
uh
as a
you put yourself
in the position to for her to stand on
you as a like a leaning post she treats
you with disregard disrespect and you
continue to do the same thing yes so
you're crushing yourself to satisfy the
woman to be in the presence okay so
you're talking about the girls like like
bombs basically like they're dating
bombs and then the guys don't have
anything to offer nobody
so even if he has something to offer for
example will smith he didn't have to go
on the stage and embarrass himself like
that then jay the turnaround was like
yeah why did he do that like you're
undermining the man in your life who
you're married to right so if okay let
me reword it but if you have to
undermine yourself to satisfy the woman
you're with you're a simp
you're right
but i'm saying like vice versa doesn't
the woman have to give up herself in
order to build a family isn't that
that's part of being a woman
like you have to undermine yourself like
part of being feminine is letting the
man lead and letting him have the
spotlight but
there's no issue it's about having a
balance between the two parties if you
have to undermine yourself as a man you
can't be a leader you can't have the
vision and the we weren't talking i was
talking about the other way around oh as
a woman yeah so you're saying i i
understand what a cem is other way
around yeah so as a woman
you know
well for me i'll talk for myself
i don't have a problem compromising if
it's for family there's an end goal we
have a goal in mind um if what about
just for a man
but what i wouldn't just do it for a man
there must be a comment but that's
that's the problem wait so is it because
because that that indicates yourself
that you're self-centered because you
wouldn't just do it for a man you have
to get something you let me
you have to get something out of it yeah
and and so like if you wouldn't just do
it like you put just for a man yeah but
for a man you have to have actual value
in my life i wouldn't just do it for my
friend i wouldn't just do it for the guy
down the road right i know but in this
conversation we're talking about a guy
you're dating oh okay i think like
that's easy
yeah that's part of the relationship
dynamic you know compromise
understanding having communication
skills this is where you find the
balance between each other to have a
relationship and i think if as a man you
have to divide yourself to be with that
woman she's not for you
most men in today's society have to
undermine themselves to some level to be
um desirable to a woman because even
something like monogamy is a man
undermining himself to please a woman
isn't it
well i i wouldn't know you would know
more than i yeah why are men expected to
deal with our hormones when we're on our
period but we're not expected to deal
with men's hormones like i'm being corny
of course you get it that's youtube yeah
lazy
so
we expect monogamy right
yeah but i think you know in this
society women are hypersexualized so if
you feel no we sexualize ourselves don't
put that hyper-sexualized that like that
word takes accountability off of women
we sexualize ourselves yeah we do
sexualize ourselves but we are hyper
sexualized in the domain so for me when
i'm looking at women twerking jumping up
and down and then saying i'm not gonna
you know beat down on my man like how he
wants
you're a hypocrite you're you're
hypocrite you're not you're not so no no
really like if a man's asking you you
know babe i need this and you're saying
no well there's 300 other girls in this
dm that will give that to him without
any questions are so
as i said if you have to undermine
yourself to be with somebody man or
woman
it's not worth it well in terms of our
reproductive strategies yeah a woman's
reproductive strategy is monogamy that's
how you safeguard yourself and
ensure the future of your offspring for
a man
um we are expendable like we die and we
go to war and we go out and hunt all
that kind of stuff so our reproductive
strategy is scattergun so we conform to
the female standard to keep his law
happy so we essentially minimize our
biological impulses to make sure that
he's not happy so to that you're
undermining yourself now
well
what is a man as a man yeah well in
society this is what we've accepted as
the norm if you if you could you say yes
or no to the question is he under are
they undermining themselves in that
situation i i'm not in that position
but i'm asking you like because a lot of
times like when girls are in a corner
they don't like they don't answer the
question yeah so i i yes or no are you
undermining yourself whether they're
getting ready
yes in the sense of biologically you are
undermining yourself but this is what
we're talking about we're talking about
standards
versus biology biology dictates that
boom you can have sex with 100 women get
100 women pregnant
a woman can only be pregnant once a year
her bio biology biology dictates that
basically by the time she's 45 she's
dried up she's no use to the average man
now men are aware of this yeah
biologically and
straight away we know this so it's a
choice that they make to be with that
woman nobody's forcing them to be in
that situation
i wouldn't necessarily say he's
undermining himself but he's making a
conscious decision to look at the women
available on the market as we've
identified low quality
not as a majority but as you so you're
almost flipping your answer you said yes
and now you're saying no what do you
mean do you think a man is on the mind
himself
no do i think he's undermining himself
biologically yes but societally no
because he knows the standards
what matters that's not fair is it yeah
because that benefits women
so it's like women like we're in a
society where everything benefits us
yeah but we mean dry ups
i feel like okay if someone's a
christian
you would be putting your body under
because biblically you want you want to
you are monogamous you're faithful
somebody of the islamic faith would say
what percent of men do you think really
are that religious that they don't want
to have sex with a lot of girls
no no what percentage of them i get it
but you know so so i think if we had a
jar in the middle that said but this
exception and pathetically
most men they would like the mother of
their child to only be one right and
then they
if they create offspring the majority of
men will say i would like to only have
one mother that's cat
no one no yeah no
yeah
no they don't want several baby mothers
okay but they but they like some side
chicks
that's true you just don't get them but
but but jason derulos little like baby
mama can go on social media and complain
and cry about how jason dorillo cheated
on her when you're dating jason derulo
what do you think was going to happen so
you're saying that whoever you get with
you should expect that's what i'm saying
i'm saying i'm saying if you want a guy
on a certain level he's going to cheat
on you okay like i'm just saying like
don't don't yeah don't be dating these
celebrities these nba players and
confuse but and i'm saying like we
wouldn't like them
if they couldn't cheat we like got like
pre-selection is very important for
women
so it's really important to us that we
see other women like the guy that we
want i feel like guys i've had guys say
if a girl if a guy does not approach my
woman i like i need that to see that
no
if a guy if a guy if a guy sees an
instagram that has a thousand or less
followers it's private
no he's not good but i'm saying like if
instagram is the extreme right and i
take you take it to the extreme to like
look at the argument so if a dude if a
girl has a million guys thirsting over
her on on instagram even if it's not
sexual content is that a green flag or a
red flag
red yeah red
what about eddie wouldn't you feel a bit
of validation this don't trust me too
that's my plan i might feel a bit of
validation but i don't want it
there's a proverb that says marrying a
pretty girl is like planting crops next
to a busy street because everyone's
going to pick up the crop but like you
would rather have a woman that you knew
was beautiful that no one moved to
that's why i wouldn't see that's
impossible
the difference is women are attracted to
that like when a guy's in a room and you
can tell other girls want him that's
attractive to us
that's attractive like when drake's in
the club the girls aren't thinking oh no
too many girls want him like nah nah
they're they're moving to drake but
vice versa guys aren't attracted like
they're not saying oh that's so hot
that that guy approached my girl i'm so
turned on right now
it's not hot no it's not hot but i've
heard some guys say like like someone's
gonna back you up i'm saying like some
guys will
like the validation right if you walk in
the room i don't know
if you walked in the room right now it
was a party and you walked in and your
girl and the whole room went quiet
mm-hmm and you're saying yo to everybody
yeah
but he's a girl but everyone's looking
at her the validation is guest bro the
validation and wanting are two separate
things
you would feel a bit of validation for
it yeah but you don't necessarily want
it because you know it's impossible it's
like it's just just one of those
i'm a man so i'm territorial so all that
sense with that situation is potential
trouble yeah i don't want that yeah i
know for a fact that someone's going to
test my character by trying to move to
my girlfriend that shit's going to get
them
but then you should know your woman and
know she's going to shut it down are you
telling me that you would rather go for
an average thing that you're not going
to get too territorial over or you'd
rather go before so it's not about being
territorials about what is what makes
most sense in the situation i probably
wouldn't be in certain situations with
my girl i would expect her to know
better 100 or just stay at home
who
wants to improve more
men are women
men
i think men want to improve more because
they have to because
their value comes from what they can
create for themselves
so they have to
men definitely i was going to say i feel
like women want to improve on their
looks men just want more money and
things to offer but we both want to
improve
on different things but if women want to
improve more on looks then why are women
more overweight than men
yeah are they yes are they
yes
i don't know something like 70 percent
of women in america are avoiding maybe
it's not it's not that much better here
it's not i don't i don't have the stats
off the top of my head but i've looked
it up before the worst in europe
yeah yeah because because you guys are
always everyone i'm from america
everyone talks [ __ ] to me and like
and i'm like and i looked up the stats
here i'm like it's not much better
it i think i think uh as an overweight
person i can probably speak on this
it helps a man to get more money
regardless of what he looks like
but for a woman she can improve
herself and it wouldn't really make a
difference to how she's treated in most
situations because not all women are
eights or tens
so i think
my person what i'm saying with it like a
five with a banging body like she still
gets a ton of attention but what what
you're calling the five mm-hmm a certain
man might not call a five he might call
you eight or two mm-hmm so i think no
but there's general standards there is i
do feel like there's more motivation
needed to improve yourself as a woman
well for myself i've struggled with my
weight so i know that the motivation i
put into my business for example i
haven't put it into myself in the same
way
but i know that because my business is
thriving the same energy i put into that
i can use it and apply it into my weight
but i feel like there's some there's a
lot of women out there who maybe they
don't have the mental capacity because
they haven't achieved anything or they
haven't successfully done something for
themselves so that there's that lack of
motivation to even look at themselves
yeah i think it's down to the fact that
men um women are born of value whilst
men have to create their value
so even as a woman you can just walk out
there on the street someone's gonna
cater to you in some way shape or form
as a man before you even get awarded a
seat at the sexual marketplace table you
need to become something you need to be
worth something if you're lucky enough
to be born good looking young then
that's your entrance but for most men
that's not the case for most women you
can be but ugly as long as you've got a
ton ton someone's going to try and stick
it somewhere so i think that's the
fundamental difference you have to
acknowledge that you're born of value
whilst we have to create our best do you
think if you couldn't get a relationship
that you would lose weight quicker if
you got no attention from men in the
world
i probably wouldn't be overweight i
think i've i've always said my problem
is i still get attention yeah
and now the attention is even different
because
you know the body shape i have looks
like the body shape that women are
paying for
so for me it's annoying because even
though it's i shouldn't really compare
myself to people i'm annoyed i'm like i
just wish i i hated myself but enough to
change wouldn't you say in a way that's
men bailing out women for bad decisions
in a way
yeah because yeah yeah yeah probably
talking about something girl's gonna say
i've had this conversation with men
where they're like i don't care like
they've been on dates they don't
actually ask the girl what she does
because they don't care they don't care
yeah so i was gonna say so is it it's
like a shoe collection so so could you
say that like they not that they don't
want us to improve but let's say she
works at mcdonald's you don't actually
require
sometimes you don't require
much edification well yeah but they want
us to look hot yeah so they might and
they might want us to be less
argumentative
in certain aspects but maybe not in
feminine friendly submissive and it
depends on the quality of guy you're
going for the problem is that the
market's always good because there's
such a small fraction of when you're
actually worth something in society so
the men who aren't worth something are
the ones that are going to be like you
know what if she gives it up
their hyenas is ready to pounce so i
think that's part of the problem
it's funny i remember having that same
thought because i i lost a bunch of
weight like a couple years ago and i
remember having the same thought like
when i got past a certain weight that
you still get like attention but for me
it just wasn't like the attention i
wanted yeah i mean i've i've been all
sorts of sizes
um and i do notice the attention is
different when i'm smaller
um i was also younger as well but um
people do treat you differently mentally
i mean at this way i attract a certain
man i know the man if i know where to go
i know the kind of man okay but i think
when i was smaller there was a there was
a variety of men it was all races
all cultures all colors why are you able
to have this conversation and because a
lot of overweight women like get very
mad when they hear my show because i
think it's something i'm working on so
i'm trying to lose weight i'm actually
doing stuff you know yeah okay no that's
cool um
who wants do you think
would you rate yourselves one to ten the
chat wants
six
six
i would say i've watched kevin samuels i
would say an adjustable stick
[Laughter]
you don't want to get slated
i think i'm a four and a half okay
i think
when i say when i say i have this
conversation my wife quite often but
when i say a number i feel like now
nowadays i feel like i'm disrespected
when i say this number but i generally
think i'm like a six but she digs
well you're married i'd give you a hair
number for the fact yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah we just don't want to look just
yeah
i'm gonna be honest my number changed
based on what they said as well it did
affect what because i'm not going to
rate myself higher than women who are
younger than me i'm just not going to do
it
because i know i know how it is
okay what about you me
i honestly think i'm a six i think my
she might be a fool but her personality
could make you wise
attractive for your personality to take
you over i reckon i i honestly believe
i'd rather wife a girl he was less
attractive but i had a greater
personality
i don't want because i think the more
attractive a girl is the more crazy she
is because there's no one no one's ever
held her accountable she wanted the the
prop the best girl to get is a girl that
was ugly in school who blossomed into
her beauty because she had to learn to
navigate the and learn about men by
being around men because you never got
men and then now you get men
if your mind is in in the right place
then that's that's the sweet you know
what's so crazy i greet him so much
because i was a tomboy and i think i was
quite well i'm dark skinned so in school
back in the day was like oh you're dark
you're blick so i remember at the day i
consciously said i want to become a
tomboy i said so no man can tell me if
i'm pretty i'm not pretty and and then i
just became mandem i just became one of
the boys and you see that key of
navigating around the waves it is so i
think it's very true why do you think
it's okay in society for
us to say men are trash but it's not
okay for men to say women are horrors
even though it's more true i think they
can
okay no way
do you think on a public platform if
yeah you have a podcast yeah if you went
on your podcast and just said modern
women are [ __ ]
wait but is that a generalization right
but women but women generalize all the
time they say they're afraid to walk
alone at night
i think i i think women call themselves
[ __ ] in different ways so they call
himself sugar babies they call himself
but we're not talking about the women
i'm saying like why is that okay in
society
because it means that you have to accept
that the opposite sex and acknowledges
your flaw and they acknowledge that you
are a [ __ ] that's what it is
no women are sensitive
i think you know when another woman you
know as a joke you say oh you're a bee
or you know you're a [ __ ] yeah they say
like oh it's candy it's cute and candied
but when a man says it's you you know
like when a guy says to you don't look
good in those clothes you know he means
that he's not gonna say he's not gonna
say it like just to be horrible if he's
telling you oh darling you're a [ __ ]
yeah he means he means you know what it
is you've kind of been caught because
sometimes i feel like girls will be like
i've done the same friendship group it
means your whole when a man has to open
his mouth and say honestly for him
because you know men don't care about
stuff men those men only talk when they
need to you're [ __ ] babes i think a
woman a woman's got to maintain a social
capital
so a man being able to call her a [ __ ]
just diminishes the social capital
because
that's that's who you you're of value to
you're not of value to other girls
you're value to men so especially if the
guy is the guy that you like if you've
seen a chapter guy call you a horse game
it's game over
what do you think
no i agree honestly because if a guy
came up to me and said i'm a [ __ ]
i would just
i'd just think my life would say well
i'll never get my reads have you seen
the mental trash before
100 i've said it before i have said it
before yeah did you mean it no
i don't think all men are trash
that's a lie yes i do
majority
i think when you're young that it's easy
to be like this and that you know when
you grow up and there's life experiences
life humbles you exactly and i think you
realize everyone's got a bit of mental
health everyone's traumatized no
people need therapy
girls are [ __ ] the same guys and then
they're calling those guys
most men don't have sex all right
so then you do you go for a certain type
of woman because you've sat here and
said i'm an international citizen
but then you said most women are crazy
so you go for crazy women no i i know
women who are crazy kind of experienced
crazy women i remember like i said i do
this i talk to women on a regular basis
so i get stories from women who i don't
need to interact with on a normal basis
and they will tell me certain things
like i know girls who have stopped their
boyfriend from getting their dream job
because he was going to break up with
her
the type of man that you deem attractive
is very very it's a small it represents
a small minority of men which means that
he has all the options which also means
that the guys you're calling trash are
only trash cause you're all sleeping
with the same men then you want to go
around and say ah men are this i mean
that there's a whole breath of men out
there who will treat you well but you
ignore those ones to sleep with the ones
that your friends stand with your
cousin's gonna sleep with your best
friend's gonna sleep with and the men
are trash when really it's the guys
you're letting inside so what so why why
do you think it's okay to say that to
say what like men are trash you just
said you do think that why do you think
they're trying like i feel good say the
women's side honestly yeah i feel like
my recent experiences have really opened
my eyes okay men of um from all
different walks of life not that i have
slept with them for somebody else's that
that i've experienced i've seen married
women married men come to talk to me
that seem that they're in happy
relationships i'm like wow so even the
married ones cheat i've seen people that
are my age
um at trash i've seen people that are
traumatized at trash people who've been
through therapy at trash i feel like
i've just seen
all men act trash so that's why i say
that who who cheats more men are women
women don't get caught
i feel like men men cheat more honestly
i feel like mentioning more
their rates are similar
yeah
yeah and i think women lie more who lies
more men are women women women
and women
so by that logic wouldn't you say that
women get away with cheating more yeah
no but i feel like for women
so so would you say that women are
equally trash
no because i feel like women cheat when
there's a reason men cheat because as
you guys said that their hormones make
them cheat so so 20 of men are in
sexless marriages would you say that's a
good reason that if you're not having
sex with your husband that he should
cheat
yeah yeah okay so would you say and the
cheating stat is about 25 of america
would you say that's a good reason
yes
[Laughter]
no no i don't look at i mean how old did
you say you were 21. yeah i mean you're
young right but i'm saying like life is
going to show you like life will humble
you
and like life at some point you have to
take accountability for the men you date
okay and like every situation you're in
is your own fault like just
like everything again if you're the
common denominator with all these trash
men why are they interacting with you
and also can i can i just add majority
of the people that say men are trash one
they've never been raised maybe by their
father i've had male interaction outside
of sexual so their idea of men is just
what
what can that man do for me uh in a
sexual way and in a financial way so
they will say men are trash when they
don't get sex they don't get financial
gain the the guy the man resists her her
drive for him to do what she wants so we
have to look at these factors and me
personally i've never said men are trash
because i see the benefits that they
bring to my life
family wise friend no honestly i have i
have had no reason to say
men are trash
it's a blanket statement when you
appreciate the benefits that men bring
into the arena you actually realize we
need them and they need us and i think
there's a lot of buzzwords that just
come from tick-tock
no actually actually
um
men
don't need women women need men men
could survive without women if all the
women disappeared tomorrow men would be
fine outside of reproduction
women women need men so they need us for
reproduction yes so that's a poor form
yeah if tomorrow they made artificial
wombs what would they need a woman for
well
okay who's a better who's a better
companion men are women
yeah but what's the capacity but what's
the capacity for that companionship you
know
outside of children and if you if you
could get a hooker
they're they're quite it's quality
so men built the world yeah every like
all the hard jobs are done by men if we
if men disappeared tomorrow they would
society would collapse ben built the
world that we complain about yeah but
without women they can't be men they
literally can't just outside outside no
outside i'm saying but outside of that
what what do they need women for i'd say
arguably one of the driving forces for
men doing what they do is women it's
women i'd say i was going to answer him
because he's married because i feel like
i can't believe this world for women but
then do you think outside of what i'm
saying what i'm saying is men could
survive without women
because men can be alone women can't
women are social beings
we thrive we need attention
yeah and men men don't so a man can like
live by himself in the like you don't
see women going out to the woods and
just roughing it that's a man thing
you know
who's camping and fishing it's not us
that's true like all the hard jobs are
done by men and and so
even so like you still say things like
men are trash and it's not like you're
21 so i'm not like most girls do at that
age it's not i feel like when they say
it correct me from wrong i feel like
when they say it's in the context of
like relationships that's what she was
saying like outside of relationships
when you've got other males around you
whether it's a brother
father whatever you appreciate men
anyway just for the other things yeah
yeah but then they'll go and say mental
trash anyway which is a very broad
statement and that's what i'm saying
it's a buzzword they don't mean it
because they're in their lives they want
the men that they have no no i genuinely
think i'm not saying every girl means it
but like society paints that even even
look at look at everything on tv it's
always the the dumb dad what's on the
simpsons
it's everything everything watch
commercials it's always like the guy
doing something stupid the woman coming
to the rescue women are queens women
empower men women women women there's no
men's empowerment people would laugh
yeah but that's so it disenfranchises
men men are more likely to take risks
than women men put themselves on the
line in more scenarios than women men
put themselves forward physically in the
place of a family it's only because of
this society that we're currently in
where they give it with this full sense
of you can be at the front of the line
you can do this like if there was a
scenario where there was actually danger
right now you know every moment
every man in this room where you
naturally
make sure that every woman in this room
is absolutely and and they accept that
but then when it comes to the financial
um the household the work now it's all
about we're equals women empowerment we
can do it by ourselves but really we
need each other and that's how it's it's
by design but i'm saying biologically
yeah i'm saying women
men don't need women outside of
reproduction
[Music]
it's true society has just made us
it's true
this is a humbling like stat that's why
people don't like this is a humbling
fact of life and that's why women don't
like to hear it
well i can't because it means we're not
as important as we think we are well i
think that
for me
i know i can see the benefits of having
men around as a woman
i aim to be a benefit to the men in my
life
and if i if i'm not okay i step to the
side and let other people step into that
role i'm not a person that will be
overly both like bolstered up and say i
am this and i'm that but i think in the
way of the world outside of this
societal um
western mentality
we sit together and we we both add value
we could say oh men could survive on
their own but realistically who wants to
have you know be lying over artificial
womb saying yeah like we wanted we
weren't
outside of western um societies like
women know their place whilst yeah i i
agree because in this society
women are not i don't know if put on a
pedestal is the right word i feel like
women they overdo it like the thing is i
believe everybody has their place like
she said and we all add value but right
now it's like oh you said she's not
pretty she's not pretty yeah and now
everyone's crying or you said you can't
you cannot cook that's a basic necessity
for your husband or for you to have a
you can't do it or i i i won't do
nothing for a man that i'm not married
and it's it's like who how much
your kids have to eat
the church do promote that you don't do
things for a man before you're married
to him well yeah but that's why like
they have single women in the church
yeah i think the church keeps smiling i
mean and they and they tell virgins to
rebrand themselves and this non as a
born-again virgin
that's
[Laughter]
he knows he knows that people are living
their lives yeah but i know what you're
talking about because when i was when i
was in high school they would always
send i went to catholic school so yeah
they would they would always bring in a
chastity speaker and it was always the
same dynamic it was the girl that's been
ran through and then found god
conveniently and only did that stuff
because she was just you know pressured
and she just felt so broken whatever
not i don't know horny
and the man is the he saved the day you
know he he swooped in
and now they make a living by her going
around saying she used to be hoe and
it's not over for the hose even though
it is over for a lot of laughing
yeah
oh my god
i don't know
there's a lady
there's a christian promise movement oh
okay go ahead yeah so my church boy yeah
when we spoke about um cheating
we mentioned that men and women cheat at
similar rates so then what what's worse
like who's worse for cheating is it man
or woman
you see i
i think emotional cheating
i feel like for me that's whoever said
you should get money for feel like it's
true you have what's your thing everyone
says i feel like i feel like emotional
cheating is worse to me because i feel
like you are more invested
your emotions you're spending time with
her you're just sexual cheating oh
sexual cheating yeah i'm gonna like you
boys take the cup for that let's not do
that no
you think it's worse from like like
what's worse i feel like in this day and
age i feel like people are on par i feel
like men and women are on par
i don't know
do you think do you think do you think
cheating is the same men for women and
men and for women oh no as in okay i
think everyone's cheating the same
however in society i feel like it's
worse what's more damaging to
a relationships a man would leave like
jay the way that and what's his name
whatever his name is because of a text
back and at the end of the day when you
bruise a man's ego even if that's the
love of his life he's leaving because
all the man them are laughing at him
let's start the truth i think i
is damaging when the man cheats and the
woman finds out
because then he starts assuming she's
going to do it and then
i think
i think so a man can a man can cheat get
away with it if nobody knows
a woman can cheat and she's done
if a man cheats and the woman knows and
stays and stays
he's going he can't deal with the fact
that she stayed with him
so he starts manipulating blaming her
for the cheating and saying it's her
four whereas is actually your nature you
cheated cause you could have been her
fault
maybe i mean i mean in most
circumstances it it there's a reason
there's always a reason but there's
times where the man just manchester's
he just gets women so question would you
guys be willing to share a guy
if if um he
would you guys be willing to share a guy
if he checked off all your boxes and he
took care of the bills if i wasn't
christian yeah i was just gonna say that
if i wasn't a christian yeah
yeah but i'm gonna lie my muslim values
are my beliefs
are you guys virgins i cannot do that
are you guys virgins
it's just like it's almost like picking
and choosing right when christianity
benefits you
no but i feel like that's all religion
no one's perfect and you can't like yeah
i know but to say like like this sexual
thing like i'm not saying you're saying
it's okay but i'm saying like i could do
this one but he couldn't do that like
it's just women oftentimes pick the
double standards that like benefit them
and not the ones that don't so wait the
question is would you stay with them
yeah
and the reason you said no is you said
because you're a christian so i said if
that's true are you a virgin
because like why would he marry you if
you're not a virgin aren't you both
getting a bad deal do you guys actually
marry for virginia is that a thing no
but if like religiously religiously so
i'm saying like he's getting a bad deal
because i'm assuming right i just assume
over certain age girls aren't virgins
right and so he's getting a bad deal so
like in that case you'd get the benefit
but you wouldn't get any cost
i mean as a typical woman my my thought
process is how does it benefit me so i
came from a family where my mom my my
grandfather had two wives they all lived
in the house together and the children
everyone stayed in house and everyone
gets along really yeah okay um back home
in nigeria okay um
and i could see how it benefited them
for that time i'm just like my question
is how would that benefit me now ticks
all your boxes yeah because i mean
at that
okay you said you have kids right i have
one you have one kid yeah and how old
are you i'm 34. so would you would you
say that over a certain age you got a
lower quality of guy interested
maybe i don't want to say i'm not trying
to disrespect
so i'm saying in this case you have you
have a man now i would admit to is i do
attract a lot of married men okay yeah
i'll admit to that i do attract married
men whether i entertain it or not
yeah it's a question what i'm saying so
in this case he would check all your
boxes because i'm sure
so life-changing yeah like he's taking
care of the bills you don't you can't
you can get that trainer
because you don't go to work anymore do
you know what let me let me be real let
me have a thing if if he came to me and
said you know what this is what i'm
about give me the option to think about
it
i don't know what i'd say if i liked him
i might think about it okay but if i
didn't like him then he's coming without
be like who who the hell are you to give
me those scenarios i think i'm selfish i
don't know if selfish is the word i just
feel like everyone deserves somebody for
themselves i feel like why can't like he
have someone for himself i don't think
anyone deserves anything i think if
you're a shitty person you don't deserve
love fair enough but i think i'm not
that shitty so
i just think personally
i think men cheat anyway so i think
that's behind my thought pro is like if
they're doing it anyway if you've come
to me and said this is how you move um i
feel like i appreciate the fact that
you're telling me how'd it be i could do
it
i would love to okay questions would you
do it would you do it at 35 with a kid
no
what if what if okay yeah i don't know
right now
i don't think i could just because i
just feel like i would just want to be
loved and loved loved by one person and
i would want to give that to him all
your bills are being taken care of but
the bills might not matter necessarily
yeah each individual realistically most
people it will but say all your boxes
are ticked everything whatever that is
to you
everything's ticked but you've got this
one i think one
one box would be that like i would want
you that's what i'm saying call it
selfish i would want you for myself and
then i know me i'm just gonna get
jealous i'm just gonna be upset so
there's no plane okay so by this logic
do you guys believe that sex is a duty
yes yes 100 percent yeah do you guys
believe a man has a right to cheat if
you say no to sex
no right is this not wait no no no no
contextualization okay so if he says i
want to have sex you say no he says okay
so if you're not going to have sex with
me i'll find someone who will
consistently if
he's saying it with that vim then i'll
respect it because he's telling me what
he's going to do but if he's like he's
just gone to cheat and he's come back
and he's like oh you didn't want to have
sex with me so i did this i'd be like
that's disrespectful do you just want to
yes or no or are you on your period
maybe you've had like like are there
things because women that don't give sex
i think that's very mad because if a
girl is continually sexless does he have
a right to cheat he would yeah no but
there's a reason for everything if
you're in a relationship or marriage and
you're not happy or fulfilled or you're
not fulfilling your partner there's a
reason people don't just do things you
have no reason yeah okay but the reason
typically is that she didn't marry the
guy she wanted she needed kids then she
should so that yeah but
what does he have no but i'm saying she
doesn't she knows she can't do better
she knows time's running out she's she's
around 30 right time's taken she wants
kids she she marries the first guy she
can find if she's smart she knows he's
doing it anyway but he he doesn't know
because a lot of times this isn't the
guys that can cheat he doesn't know that
she's marrying her second choice the
same way will didn't know
there were some warning signs but
yeah yeah she cried on the wedding day
on the wedding day yeah yeah
yeah you know what he's not a great
example
a lot
a lot of guys don't know they're a
girl's second choice but if you're her
friend you you know
you're like you guys know your girl's
dating a guy she doesn't really want
yeah you know and those are the guys
that don't get the sex
and then the girls are come back
heartbroken when he or you know now
they're mad when he cheats but like she
wasn't sleeping with him to begin with
i just feel like people should have
conversations yes
rather than cheat just end it like but
women fall in love what they hear
from love what they see
but then have a comment like for me it's
just the logic have a conversation
okay i
i agree with you but put yourself in
their shoes okay so so so you let's say
you're married to a girl again you don't
know that you are her second choice she
stops sleeping with you after she gets
what she wants the kids
now what could you do you could leave
but you put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage you possibly
could like they're more likely to go to
prison they're more likely to run away
they're more likely to fail out of
school every statistical disadvantage
you could put your could have it that's
your choice
option two is to divorce her
and she you're she's entitled to child
support she can get collect alimony and
in the u.s like she can literally take
half your [ __ ]
and your third option is you know what
i'm gonna just cheat
you know i'm gonna die if i if if i'm to
put myself in a guy's perspective yeah i
would just think what is my game not
that good then put up would be go cheap
100 because that's the easier safer
option and pray that she don't find out
yeah
so that's why guys do it a lot of the
time i'm not saying some some guys are
just cheaters like that's just they're
gonna do that regardless but like that's
a lot of times when guys cheat it's
because their wife isn't giving them
anything i've had guys send me stories
where they're they like don't know what
to do because they love their wife they
want to be with their wife but she won't
sleep with him it's been a year what is
it
that's mad do you think men marry the
person they love or who's ready when
they're ready i i think it's who's ready
when they're already but like partially
but at the same time men and women love
different because i think men can love
more than one girl at a time
where where women can only love one at a
time
and she has to view that guy as like the
best that she could get and if she feels
like that like this guy was the best i
could do like he'll be in her head
forever
like i had a comment section when i was
explaining this concept there was a
woman who was 80 that said there was a
guy that she met when she was 21 that
she still thinks about every day
wow yeah i'm trying to do that
[Laughter]
wait do you guys agree with the
statements i was talking to one girl one
time she said um
she's in a 14-year relationship so i
said you know your man's probably like
cheating like every night again
and she said to me
as long as i'm happy and it doesn't
bring that nonsense home
that is fine so do you agree with that
statement i've heard this by from
several women
in this day and age because everybody
the pressure is getting you know what
the problem with cheating is it's it's
not the action is people being reckless
it's the whole so just did i use the
condom
what if he's not what i'm saying he said
well i used the condom though would you
be like no where is it sometimes it's
not what you say is how you say wait is
it 14 years of marriage or of a
relationship because i feel like like
she's you to get married but then she
just said if i'm happy in this
relationship and you've never given me
any reason to doubt you even though i
know you're a man and probably do it as
long as i never find out
and i'm happy let's be honest i feel
like a lot of women are not accepting
that anyway a lot of women are in
situations where they've just accepted
would you not accept that though are you
happy to live by that standard
what like the whole outside out of mind
yeah but it's just i think i've never i
think we do it anyway i think we do it
anyway
women do that if i ain't seen nothing i
ain't quote you
and i think it
like
but if you know they could probably
gonna do it anyway why is it such a
madness when it does get caught
but that's all emotions that's a
different like you have to delve deeper
because that's emotions that's important
no no i'm saying like if you know that
he's going to do it anyway like why is
it a big deal when he gets caught wait
are we saying that oh menchie is that is
that
the man that you're attracted to the man
that most women are attracted to will
probably cheat at some point in let's
say you're gonna be married for 40 to 60
years of your life at some point this
guy's going to step out yeah so you all
know what happened if you do buy
whatever circumstance you catch the guy
cheating
in your mind you already know he's an
attractive man he's got options he's
loyal the majority of the time
and i expect this to happen why is it
still a madness for you can i ask you a
question
if you cheat on a woman and she doesn't
react what do you think what are you
going to think if she doesn't really
scared if she don't really if she don't
react question if she finds out you've
cheated and she's like okay cool that's
based on what is inside no no about
actually yeah it's unexpected but you
can answer my question
would you be would you answer would you
be excited
would you be like this is i gotta wipe
her now
or like she she's about to kill me next
time let me let me run it's about to do
some spiteful [ __ ] that's what i'm
i think about this this context because
i look at my parents for example
my dad stepped out my mom a couple times
but my mom knew that it was she she knew
it wasn't a thing but this is this is
like when they were younger she knew
like men would be men because in nigeria
they knew what men were like so it
wasn't a big deal and the men knew it
wasn't a big deal so that's how society
functioned in today's society we know
that women are hyper-sensitive so i
expect a reaction because that's that's
what the society teaches but in reality
again if you really know what's going to
happen why does it why does it need such
a madness do you get one then there's
levels of reaction
there's levels like there's there's
going to instagram i'm posting on your
on your status about like my jordan
exactly and then there's
dealing with him at home and saying you
know what like i'm i'm in the mood right
now and i think some reactions mean that
you care that if you don't react i would
kind of assume what i'm saying she said
she don't care it'll be like she don't
care your stomach just starts to hurt
you're like
um okay i'm gonna read super chats for a
sec okay guys all super chats are going
towards the new studio look at i'm i'm
for looking at apartments right now
and all of these super chats make me
think of what apart like how big we're
gonna go
and i looked at such a nice one today i
want it so bad but it's kind of
expensive we'll see we'll see okay so um
aaron miller two dollar super chat thank
you so much the uk economist please ask
if a man can deny his duty
oh i'm gonna come back i'm gonna come
back to that okay
success chaser the only reason she can
say all men are trash is because another
man is across is across seas protecting
her from men that want to use her as a
304 tool many soldiers are are gone
protecting a girl like her 90 free toe
pie two men one woman she will fight
because of
two men one woman she will cause a fight
for spite or boredom two women one man
he will love them both and provide keep
it going pearl with the no vague
non-answers j watts simpson in cells who
made them men or women
jonathan farley yes men should marry
virgins that was no the norm generations
ago plus any other woman is an alpha
widow lawrence bullock questions for
women why is it that when a man cheats
it's a hundred percent his fault but
when a woman cheats she automatically
blames the man she cheated on
that's so true 90 free toe pie women are
too stupid for hypotheticals ian mack
woman cheating is worse no woman has
ever lied to about
about whose child women cheating is
worse no woman should ever has ever been
lied to about whose child they are
raising
red mean green so how can we cheat if we
aren't chad javier collin
it's not about men protecting women men
in general are hot wired to protect
those that can't protect themselves that
includes men that can't defend
themselves and children
big wow 777 what's the green yellow
what's the yellow green dresses
instagram
who am i yeah green and yellow jennifer
um red red mean green um we can't really
need women if you're not there 90 free
topi alex de gray ruled for the women
matt butcher reality show idea two
islands minimal resources no shelters 10
men on one island 10 women on the other
ready go mgtow mgtow by logic women
choose oh god women choose trash felons
have 30 percent more kids than
non-felons
well
excuse me
sentient so 50 super chat let's go
um their hormones made them cheat oh no
i sucked a new d it's because of santa
claus
butt cake the moonlight reflecting off
the swamp grass tricked out while strung
out on party favors saturn penetrating
venus smh what an utter lack of
accountability
wendy jesus women that call men are
projecting takes trash to no trash
90 free toe pie it may not be your fault
but it is your responsibility mgtow by
logic no one's going to catch me
cheating because i'm a gentleman k maul
listen folks because a five means you're
equal or better looking than half the
people you meet a seven is equal or
better looking than seventy percent of
the people you meet that's how numbers
work
humbled
shark one women lie and say they are i
with the boys women lie and say it's
yours
um
red mean green how wow how can 80 of
unpounded men cheat brainwash 90 free
topi the men in your life are trash ata
patrice 1 to 30 scale 1 to 30 is ugly 11
to 20 is average 21 to 30 is gorgeous
the one to get 10 scale problem is that
a six is too close to 10. wendy jesus
people don't hold accountability nor
therapy honey wendy jesus yellow dress
you're not a fork stop justifying being
overweight and stop making excuses
you're not fooling anybody dog bird zero
two a woman can be ugly fat poor and
still go to the club and find someone to
take them home men need looks money and
status for that zodiac two five six b
what is sad is about a woman improving
herself is that a relationship is
actually dangerous
what is what is sad about a woman
improving herself that is in a
relationship it is dangerous to the
relationship due to hypergamy if she
ever matches or overcomes her man she is
gone
no i'm not reading that super chat stop
super chatting again
zodiac thank you for the five dollar
super chat zmj women are competitive she
wants derulo to herself she wants derulo
to herself to signal that she's of high
status the level of self-validation
backfired just get a person with a
religious background y'all y'all at
least they they'll think three times and
pray on it before they go f things up
red mean green i wish modern women would
look more into money currencies aren't
real you're selling yourself for nothing
trading love for nothing at all to shame
how you run after these high value men
90 free tote pie why can't women be
grateful in being wanted eli you should
listen to dvsn's new song if i get
caught
bali bam he's not controlling he's in
control alistar horton
most women over sexualize themselves
because it's all they can offer to the
independent man that they seek 90 free
topi what regular guy has 300 dms ata
weak men are dangerous men simps are
weak men fifth fan uh super 100 super
chat let's go
um for the ac please please thank you um
i'm the prize shows a greater likelihood
that you're looking down on your partner
and will only prioritize your happiness
al i meant to say my guy ish not my ish
the ten dollars to clear that up is
worth it um zj13 first time catching
alive keep up the good fight pearl the
red lens keep up the good work pearl i
love the show al hello from brooklyn new
york shout out to you and my
to you and my oh and my guy ish keep
that accountability coming pearl p.s
those milky legs are fire thank you
rick cormier the idea of i would delete
it for my husband but not my boyfriend
is so funny you will not be promoted to
wife if you cannot trust him as a
boyfriend zero fallout this is your
future ladies if things don't change
alone with pets or baby mom number five
regular men will leave with what regular
men will leave with will leave you with
pookies and incels
civilization is a contract built on the
premise that men will have a wife
sentience
oh that was the instagram so i'm going
to go back to a super chat
that someone asked earlier
please ask if a man can deny his duty to
physically protect his wife
can a man deny his duty to physically
protect his wife if a woman can deny sex
emotion at the night
well men they're not allowed to deny
that
they're just not allowed the way society
is set up if you're
denying your wife
of that protection then you're not
serving your vows that's what they were
saying okay what do you think
i guess why not if women can deny sex
then why not
i personally wouldn't because it's just
wired into me like that's normal
all right so let's say you got a girl
right and
the night before she said no to sex yeah
i'm fuming mom and you're human the next
day someone breaks into the house
[Laughter]
what you what you doing now for comedic
reasons
i'm gonna obviously
no i can't even do it even
like i can't even live it's just in me
what if she what if she hadn't had sex
with you in a year oh [ __ ] then that
that's different i wouldn't even be
there
that's the truth you got a kid you got
it you got a kid you're still there for
the kid i'm not there for the kids i see
the kids
[Laughter]
see the kid every weekend we're good but
now it's just wired into us i think all
the guys here can agree like women kids
siblings younger people vulnerable
people it's just normal like it's just
my natural instinct regardless
i was just moving it closer no no
you're next oh i don't actually get what
you mean so physically as in if somebody
breaks in he should protect me is that
what yeah because in a marriage that's
what you're that's what you're
um that's the deal
you you give sex you give sex and
commitment and loyalty he gives you
protection and provisioning do you know
what i feel like if he denied those
things i know it sounds manipulative
but if he denied those things to prove a
point it sounds so manipulative that
maybe the woman will understand a bit
more where he's coming from by his need
for sex in the relationship so maybe
that might change her behavior and
they'll live happily why are you getting
[ __ ] up
no no no no obviously
yeah it sounds a bit mad
no broken nose later i know
now
have my
[Laughter]
do all the women here expect that from a
guy though yeah yeah definitely security
yeah definitely definitely one that i
just
one that i'm dating not a stranger no
yeah it's that aspect of my brother my
dad someone i'm dating yeah not a brand
yeah and guys do you will expect sex
from our partner yes come on that's okay
why are you
just understanding yeah just making sure
we're all on the same page
what about you what do you think
if women can turn down sex can when can
men turn down security
or protection yeah i want to say
i technically yes but do you understand
that all right sex is penetrative
right mm-hmm how many times do you
really have to beat up someone for your
life
how much say that say that's so all
right so my point is uh sex is is a
regular occurrence it's just a regular
healthy relationship cool like let's be
realistic how often is someone break
like how okay so i think the question
should be how many times does a man
actually have to like
do protecting like i get it mentally and
things but actually someone's attacking
your woman or breaking in into your
house i feel like for the world to
function men have to protect us all the
time like we wouldn't be able to walk
we wouldn't be able to do anything like
like why do you think women couldn't
vote why do you think women didn't have
like why do you think women didn't fight
in wars
the only reason the world is stable
today
as an example yeah okay that's one
example but okay who do you call you
call the police do you want a man or a
woman coming
oh man feminism if if
we broke out into if we had if england
was in war today
i know here you guys can be equally
drafted but come on are they putting
women on the front lines are they
putting men who's getting drafted
first men get drafted first yeah
if we're putting it on the same pedal
store sex i believe a man can do that
but obviously it's not nice because
she'll be hurt and she won't be pretty
anymore but he'll be horny and upset
yeah i think no way but i feel like you
lot would i feel like it would burn you
guys more that you didn't protect rather
than
well the point is that we don't
appreciate that men protect us all the
time
i don't know like we can be
they protect us in a world where we
choose not to be with them
like and they built the world for women
and i think it's not just protection in
a sense that oh there's danger let me
get in the way of it but it's also like
looking for potential dangers so i'm
constantly thinking how can like if my
wife goes out i'm thinking i look at her
outfit and i'm like
okay what could potentially happen here
and i would say something if i think
something could happen or if i'm out and
about i'm just like i'm aware of dangers
because my instinct is to protect if
that makes sense so that's a constant
thing it's not just like when someone
breaks into the house who's more likely
to be helped if they're attacked in
public men or women women
so men are protecting us all the time go
ahead i think off the back of what he
said um
i feel like a woman really and truly
shouldn't have sex with a man she
doesn't feel protected by
if if a woman is in a situation where
she where she's not giving sex maybe she
doesn't feel protected
i think i think that they do it to
manipulate man yeah i think like
i mean that's why it's really common
like one thing i always hear is that
you know he takes out the trash so so he
can get laid
he's like working he's like in the
relationship and used sex as
manipulation right because you probably
genuinely like you probably genuinely
desired your partners yeah but a lot of
women marry guys they're not really
attracted to because they want the
resources
or the children you probably genuinely
have desired your partners i think women
are most likely to just use their bodies
for protest anyway
so
not having sex could be a form of
protest when you see women at protest
they're usually taking their clothes off
so i think that's just something that
women do i think women know that their
bodies are their weapon
that's why women go crazy when a guy has
sexual discipline yeah
like if i get like i've seen it myself
where a girl's throwing herself at me
and if i don't react to it just get mad
used to it she would lose her mind yeah
so it's like it's like a man this arm in
your greatest weapon
do you guys think that's true i think it
depends on the kind of woman yeah no i
think it's true
i think it's true
what are you thinking no i just
that's what i'm saying if we're
generalizing i hear it but maybe like me
personally i just don't feel that i
would
so when i was at university i took a
year as sexier to learn sexual
discipline here
and
i remember very specific situations
where literally girls trying to whip my
trousers down just because of that what
do you mean like you're not like going
literally just going to skip something
that's cringey wow
that's really crazy to me that's crazy
if you talk to mandom that's it's a
normal thing if a man turns on a girl
it's like how could you turn me down
when i'm giving you sex like what who do
you think you are but then doesn't that
tell you a bit about her like if if sex
is such on a high pedal stool to her but
that's the thing i think if you if women
can't handle rejection that's what i
wanted to say
so it's like you're getting rejecting is
like me giving you my body is like one
of my biggest offerings and you're
turning that down
i think it's because we're used to men
wanting sex so badly that when we
finally come across one that isn't moved
by it we're like what is going on here
do you know what i mean so that's why in
some cases it's used as a form of
manipulation yeah i agree with that
women do that a lot
yeah
yeah but remember women don't have any
other bargaining chips other than that
they don't what other bargaining chips
do women have yeah they used to in the
1950s i mean like i think women from the
1950s would think we're so weak today
they'd be like oh you left your man
because you weren't happy my man had a
whole family across town and i stayed
yeah yeah yeah and and culturally i
think
like having a moroccan background myself
it's
having more than one wife is i have free
grandmas not biologically but i have
three grandmas my mom has 18 siblings
it's not something that affects me that
deeply but i will say when it comes to
women um
in regards to bargaining chips we we
don't have much to offer because we've
we've left everything to lie on our
sexuality so when we withhold from our
our partner we're actually
damaging our relationship even though we
think we're being effective in that way
we're actually damaging our relationship
we're giving space for that man to walk
away from us and showing him that
basically
all we have is our sexuality to offer
we're not even nurturers we don't care
how we feel we don't care you know what
you've put out for us to be able to be
in this experience together
um and i think for me as an observer of
relationships the lack of appreciation
for
membrane to the table like we always say
we bring stuff to the table right we
bring stuff to the table men will bring
all kind of stuff outside of materialism
to the table and it's not appreciated
very much
what do you feel like makes women
special
is there anything that makes women
special i think what makes you special
what makes me oh wow
that's a beautiful story i think what
makes me special is i'm fortunate enough
to have understanding and integrity so
when i'm dealing with a guy i try to
understand who he is before i step into
an arena to be in a relationship with
him and
listen listen my brother you know he
always taught me like listen to what the
man saying don't just jump up because
being younger you don't know things you
learn as time goes on i used to jump up
and say what he's not listening to me
yeah what about no listen to what he's
actually saying don't make it up in your
head don't project it onto him
so for me um i think i just
what makes me special is i know how to
laugh at myself and not take myself too
seriously but when it's time i'm i'm a
nurturer i'm a natural nurturer and i
have listening skills so
what do you think makes you special
everyone um i feel like what makes me
special is that i
like to learn
um so i feel like a lot of problems in
relationship is that one of them is
stubborn one of them doesn't want to
compromise so i tried my best to always
learn about
men learn about relationships learn
about what he wants and i just expect
him to obviously do the same but i feel
like i try to be as teachable as i can
and that makes me special
okay
but wait you're as teachable as you can
but you want to delete instagram for no
i said i wouldn't if
anything but you would um yeah but
you're saying your submission costs
oh what does it cost
how much does he have to make
i would like to
not
i'd like to not work i'd like to not
work have to work what do you think that
would cost in london
um i actually don't know quite a lot
i'm just curious you're from london yeah
what do you think that would cost in
london
to be a house 120 thousand 110 more than
50. so you wouldn't sell it more than
that more than 90 200 bags
like what yeah 1750k something 200k it's
not 50. it depends how you live
okay so would you guys agree it's over
100 yes yeah so you're asking for you're
saying you wouldn't submit to 99 of guys
oh damn
that well that's not realistic so
obviously no yeah i would have to yeah
wait a hundred grand to live in london
no i've said it at least yeah i said at
least
okay there you have it i've been the top
10 in london 70k upwards it's not even
actually like 60s
yeah it's pretty bad yeah so most people
ain't even making that or near do you
feel like you're in the top one percent
of females
no
okay so why does your submission cost
what a top one percent
that's a good question
i haven't thought about it okay what
makes you special
um i think what makes me special is
i think i've learned
through life to be accountable
communication is key i think one thing
i've also learned is
loving someone how they want to be loved
i think a lot of people love someone how
they want to be loved but not actually
how the other person wants to be yeah
and then people aren't appreciative but
why would you be appreciative that's not
how you want to be loved correct so i
feel like um i'm also quite nurturing um
understanding i feel like
yeah
just the whole accountability being able
to communicate and understanding that
some people
communicate in different ways so you
have to understand everyone's different
and be willing to learn compromise and
all of that so okay what about you
uh what makes me special is that i am
self-aware
i take accountability for my actions
and um yeah that's about it so i'm
curious from the guys what if those
sounded like everything they listed that
makes them special what what what sounds
good to you
um
in terms of like being able to listen to
the guys i think like as a guy
when we communicate with women
we like if it's something that they
don't want to hear
it just goes in and out and everything
else just turns into war so if you can
get someone that actually listens to you
and is willing to
hear you
back
yes bang everyone's got good attributes
regardless but that one's a big one i
think it's the accountability part that
stood out to me because
what happens is
i think i don't know if you guys can
relate to this but if let's say for
example you had an issue with a woman
and then you told her about it
you're then also thinking uh can't make
sure i have to make sure she doesn't
feel too bad i have to make sure that
she's okay you know what i mean with
accountability you've got a good
accountability you won't have to worry
about that i shouldn't i shouldn't have
to like talk to you about
something that i don't like and then
also worry about your feelings to the
sense that i'm coddling you know i'm
more or less just worried about going
into world war three like if i say this
thing are we just gonna go to war yeah
is it that big of an issue that i'm
gonna have to bring out because if i do
we're just gonna go to war so
i think the only important one for me if
i'm being honest was um self-awareness
so i think once you have self-awareness
all the things that you mentioned is all
encompassed because you you're able to
see things from all those different
perspectives to be able to understand
your shortcomings what you need to
develop
whether you need to be accountable in
certain situations etc etc once you're
truly awake and you understand yourself
then you're able to conduct yourself
properly in other environments so for me
self-awareness is probably the most
important one
okay so i'm going to read super chats
one more time and then i think we're
going to close out the show um so think
about i'm going to say give you guys
closing thoughts only if some comments
bothered you you want to speak your
piece on something
you feel it yeah now's your it will be
your time in like five minutes um okay
guys like the video um that is the most
important metric that pushes um the
content out into the algorithm while
you're at it guys the super chats are
very much appreciated i'm trying to get
a bang in place next year okay and all
the super chats help again i'm literally
looking at places this week and gauging
by how well we do on the shows is how
i'm picking what place we're going to
get
subscribe to the channel while you're at
it
subscribe is free also go to our clips
channel because we're trying to get to
15k on that this week so silly sausage
women will leave relationships and say
they are bored without realizing that
the lack of drama and chaos is actually
what a healthy relationship looks like
they will start they will leave to
restart the toxic attention cycle
dxyb in a relationship at all no benefit
for a man out of 300 plus god out of 300
plus women i've ran through i've never
gotten distracted by one [ __ ]
focus on my square
norwegian norwegian username men and
women chief at the same rate according
to a norwegian study from 2018 the study
showed that men and women cheat at a
rate out of 4 out of 10 people [ __ ] lord
zan thank you for the super chat drasean
gaming ladies please think about this if
the law didn't matter tomorrow how many
of you do you think would be graped and
how many men would sign up to save you
[ __ ] then
verodin joreda on the question of sex
why is it that a woman's body is more
sacred than 60 to 70 hours of work at
all times in all weather that men
subject to their bodies on their behalf
isn't his body sacred silly sausage it
won't let me send any long super chats
some people send long ones i don't know
why it wouldn't norwegian username
rate studies rate shown in a study from
2018 in norway it wasn't 2017 the rate
is going the rate is four out of ten
both female and male shout out to the
norwegian username
humbled shark twas twas brilliant and
the slith tobes did
zyre and gimble in the wave all
mimsy were the
boar groves and the
mom wraths out i don't know what you're
saying okay pan-african
b-g-m-t-o-w patriarch feminism is true
pandemic patriarch sustains mr black
raven imagine living in a world built by
men you hate maria cameron pearl did you
go to elmhurst university i did i did
that's my old stomping grounds
red mean green good luck with your
apartment thank you jay yeah hard to
agree with the ladies this time a
reaction doesn't mean she cares we don't
like it but it shows a desire for the
man but black men don't cheat
mgtow by logic sorry babe i just don't
feel like paying all these bills this
month maybe next month
andrew
andrew cruz i have the right i have the
right to chat for everybody she has
aaron miller two dollar super chat the
uk economist please ask if a man can did
not i already did that one i'm gonna
refresh the page really quick just to
make sure i don't miss any like the
video while you're at it also guys sign
up for our memberships the memberships
help us put a roof off over our head
plus if you get our fourth membership
you can have one-on-one call with me
every month
ata i feel bad for the dude who broke in
because someone is getting that d
um okay
i don't know i'm not even gonna ask
questions
um okay that's all the super chat so any
final thoughts you have you know speak
your piece uh yeah no this was fun uh i
watched the show almost every week so i
i'm just happy to be here but yeah
yeah i had a good time have nothing else
to say oh check my youtube channel
jennifer cynthia
um it was great to be here first time on
the podcast i think everyone's amazing i
think as humans we should just
communicate
try our best one tip if you have one
month reviews at work do it in your
relationship
but yeah
this was fun i didn't realize men went
through so much
but yeah
had fun yeah and i really enjoyed it and
i think the women were optimistic some
women i've seen speak especially in this
day and age
say some crazy stuff but i never
actually heard anything too mad so
my closing thoughts is just
try to communicate have self-awareness
and be reflective
in a relationship
there was four super chats that came and
i'm just going to read real quick the
girls that don't communicate as well as
they think pearl understands this now
too much listening to respond they also
avoid confrontation conflict avoided is
conflict multiplied for the future oh
that's a good quote what makes you
special do you not feel that that's the
problem with today's social media
dysfunction the fact that no one is
special yet most women believe or feel
that they are you are not special
girl girl with the orange girl with the
orange dress is my favorite on the panel
i like the way she thinks also ish is
the great and powerful oz without a
camera angle
okay
um it's just gone today
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel like the video on your
way out um follow our clips channel also
subs follow our memberships we have
three tiers the five dollar ten dollar
tier we you can connect with us on
social media or have a one-on-one call
with us once a month thank you to our
member of the week zentianz if you want
to come on the show dm eddie if you
heard a voice in the background that was
eddie today so he runs um he's our
recruiting page so go that his instagram
is in the description don't forget to
subscribe to the channel like the video
on your way out and we will talk to you
next time